[Musique]
Marc échangé. Bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Marqué
Chinger 58 ans, français,
résident en Haute Savoie
avec une longue carrière qui se termine
qui a commencé d'abord avec des études
d'expertise comptable euh qui a déjà
bifurqué sur un terrain beaucoup plus
particulier qui est celui du trading.
J'ai été patron de salle des marchés
pendant plus de 15 ans.
J'ai publié pas mal de que ça soit de de
livres sur la finance ou d'articles et
j'étais assez connu pour avoir travaillé
sur les attaques qui concernent les
monnaies, que ça soit la livre avec la
banque d'Angleterre ou le taille bat en
Thaïlande, les monnaies de certains
pays. Et
après ce parcours là, à peu près en
200021, à partir du moment où il y a eu
le 11 septembre, j'ai changé de
d'activité. Je suis un petit peu resté
dans la finance mais avec d'ailleurs
déjà une orientation sur ce qui
concernait le financement du terrorisme
et euh et puis et puis ça a basculé en
allant sur des théâtres de guerre. J'ai
fondé une société qui s'appelle la PI
Capitale qui est dédiée au renseignement
économique au renseignement on va dire
tout court sur les zones de guerre euh
et et
qui vous permet euh si vous avez des
intérêts dans un théâtre de guerre
d'avoir des informations, d'avoir tout
ce qu'il faut pour essayer de
gérer la situation dans laquelle vous
avez été amené à vous retrouver du fait
de la guerre.
Alors aujourd'hui, on va parler de
terrorisme, on va parler intelligence
économique, on va parler de tout un tas
de choses dont les intérêts français à
l'étranger et comment les intérêts
français sont gérés, renseignés,
infiltrés. On va parler géopolitique du
renseignement mais avant précaution
oratoire, on fait attention aujourd'hui,
pas de diffamation,
on est précautionneux juridiquement
parlant.
Toutes les personnes qu'on va citer ont
droit à la présomption d'innocence.
Ouais.
Et on va parler de d'hypothèse de
travail pour ce qui n'a pas été jugé.
Si si les questions que je vous pose
vous amènent sur ce terrainlà.
Voilà.
Donc parlons parlons un peu
renseignement, parlons un peu de votre
histoire. Vous avez commencé alors vous
êtes décrit par Anne Navergon comme un
petit comment elle vous écrit un
un petit analyste je crois quelque chose
comme ça.
Voilà donc petit analyste financier
incompétent c'est ça doute.
C'est comme ça que vous avez
retranscrit. Ouais. Est-ce que Bon,
peut-être qu'elle a pas dit incompétent
d'ailleurs. Euh, parlons un peu
renseignement.
Comment un petit analyste euh comptable
termine à faire entre guillemets de la
barbouserie en Afrique ?
Alors, barbouserie en Afrique, c'est un
peu péjoratif. Euh, je dirais que le
chemin passe par une prise de conscience
et par idéologie. Moi, je viens d'une
famille qui a servi la France. Mon père
est un ancien enfin il est décédé mais
mais il a été à 18 ans euh il a défilé
contre les les il il s'est battu contre
les Allemands le 11 novembre 40 lors du
défilé. il a été arrêté, il s'est évadé,
il a terminé en compte concentration euh
et il m'a élevé euh
dans un état d'esprit qui était celui
euh du sens de l'honneur.
Il avait le sens du service de l'État,
mais surtout il avait des valeurs. C'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours il aurait pu
avoir la Légion d'honneur, il a toujours
refusé de la porter parce qu'il me
disait "Mais tu vois, jamais je la
demanderai, jamais je ferai quoi que ce
soit pour avoir ce cette médaille là
parce que il y a des gens qui la portent
dont je sais pertinemment qu'ils étaient
de l'autre côté pendant la guerre." et
il était resté très marqué par ça et euh
et ses compagnons de de camp qui eux
avaient cédé à la tentation et avait ce
genre de de décoration lui disait "Mais
bon, on apprécie disons ton jugement
mais il est dur et on a le droit aussi à
avoir un peu du gâteau, un peu de
remerciement et tout ça et il a jamais
voulu et c'est dans cet esprit là qu'
que j'ai été élevé et Donc aujourd'hui,
si je mène les combats, c'est des
combats que je mène sans avoir l'idée de
me rémunérer avec ou de vouloir quoi que
ce soit. L'idée même de me faire
descendre en sortant d'ici, mais
complètement
vraiment
c'est sans objet. Ça ça m'est égal.
Par qui ? parce que j'ai pas mal de gens
qui euh voudraient que j'arrête de
donner des informations euh qui doivent
pas qui doivent rester confidentielles
et de les rendre publ. Euh là, je suis
sur le 2e tome euh de pas de mes
mémoires mais mais mes disons de mes
activités. Euh je vais parler du
financement de terrorisme et de la façon
dont Daesh s'est financé par la vente de
son pétrole. C'est particulièrement
choquant pour les Français.
Donc il y a des gens qui aimeraient bien
que ça soit pas public. Euh mais il y a
heureusement des procédures en cours en
Italie qui me font penser que on va
arriver à gagner ce combat et que ça va
être public et qu'on va dire aux gens
comment da financé, par quel flux euh
par quelle société. Et les gens vont
comprendre que l'affaire la Farge qu'ils
connaissent un peu parce que bon, c'est
Lafarge, c'est un financement de 12
millions d'euros euh qui a été fait en
faveur de Daesh,
elle était à la limite laaffire la farge
un peu excusable
parce qu'il y a eu des opérations
spéciales qui sont qui ont eu lieu
autour de la cimenterie de la Farge en
Syrie. Mais là, le financement de Daesh
par son pétrole euh est totalement
inexcusable.
Pour vous en dire quelques mots
rapidement,
en 2014, à partir de 2014, Daesh
investit des champs pétrolifères dans le
nord de l'Irak, un endroit que je
connais très bien. Production est assez
faible mais
suffisante pour pouvoir créer une source
de financement importante, leur source
majeure de financement, mais ils ont pas
de moyen d'évacuer ce pétrole pour
pouvoir le vendre. Il faut le
transporter, il faut c'est pas
consommable sur place. Donc il faut, il
y a quelqu'un qui va les aider à à
mélanger ce pétrole au pétrole de
contrebande des Turcs. Euh ce pétrole va
se retrouver camionné jusqu'à Dortiol.
Et à ce moment-là, à Dortiol, il est
déchargé et chargé sur des tankers.
C'est une société française qui se
charge des opérations.
Ce pétrole est vendu à des traders.
Est-ce qu'ils sont au courant de ces
sociétés française ?
Parfaitement. Vous avez des preuves de
ça ?
Parfaitement.
Ce pétrole est mélangé donc est vendu à
des traders suiss et il est il après
avec des faux papiers, il est vendu un
peu partout notamment en Italie. Au jour
d'aujourd'hui, vous avez deux procureurs
italiens euh de Kagilari et Breschia qui
qui travaillent avec la police contre
terroriste euh pour déterminer quel flux
est allé exactement sur Daesh, quel flux
est allé exactement envers les Kurdes.
Euh mais le schéma en tout cas de
d'export de l'huile de Daesh, maintenant
on le connaît.
Et donc c'est intéressant euh de voir à
quel point euh
on le connaissait déjà. quand il y a eu
l'enquête parlementaire, il y a une
mission parlementaire qui a eu lieu en
2016, 2e semestre 2016, euh vous avez
des députés qui se demandent mais
comment se comment Da se finance. Donc
il y a une commission d'enquête
parlementaire qui est faite. Le rapport
ne mentionne strictement rien
de tous ces événements. On parle de on
parle de des de l'art de beaucoup de
choses tout ça, mais pas du pétrole de
Dalèche qui constitue 90 % de du
financement. Ce financement-là est
tellement important qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui que s'il y avait pas eu ce
flux, il y avait il y aurait pas eu le
califat et donc il y aurait pas eu les
attentats notamment je parle de ceux du
Bataclan, il y aurait pas eu les
attentats qu'il y a eu après. Et donc
c'est une trahison qu'il a eu non
seulement vis-à-vis des Français, non
seulement vis-à-vis des victimes du
Bataclan, mais aussi vis-à-vis de la
police. Et je pense aux gens de la
cellule àAT. La cellule àAT, pour ceux
qui connaissent pas, c'est une cellule
spécialisée au niveau de la DGSI qui est
chargée de travailler sur le terrain à
démanteler les filières djihadistes.
C'est un travail de chien, c'est un
travail extrêmement dur.
Il est évident qu'à partir du moment où
Daesh peut financer son chalifat, eux
ils vont énormément souffrir. C'est
beaucoup d'activités qui vont avoir à
gérer.
Et tout ça aurait pu
être arrêté en amont si on avait empêché
Daesh d'exporter son pétrole. Donc si on
avait pas camionné, si on avait pas
déchargé les camions, chargé les
bateaux.
Revenons, revenons à votre histoire.
Oui.
Comment on fait pour bosser ? Comment on
fait pour être un honorable contributeur
de la DGS ?
Alors, vous avez plusieurs
Vous avez bossé pour eux ?
Oui, j'ai bossé pour la DGS. C'est pas
le seul. C'est
Vous êtes sûr que c'était la DGSE ?
Oui.
Comment vous êtes sûr de ça ?
C'est J'ai aucun doute, il y a pas de
souci.
D'autant que la DGSE n'aime pas que vous
travaillez pour d'autres services alors
que moi j'avais un principe et je l'ai
toujours, c'est de dire quand vous avez
la possibilité de collecter une
information importante, il faut que
cette information soit utile. Utile
utiliser. Et ceux qui peuvent
l'utiliser, c'est pas forcément ceux
pour lesquels vous travaillez, c'est pas
forcément votre chapelle. Or, à la DGSE,
on vous dit bah on ne prie que dans une
seule chapelle
qui est
qui est celle de la DGS. quand vous êtes
rémunéré par la DGSE comme contractuel
et et que ça se passe comme ça.
C'est un état dans l'État.
Alors, vous avez vous avez des gens
c'est
un état dans l'État.
C'est pas un état dans l'État. C'est
c'est un service qui doit travailler
pour le bien du contribuable et de la
France et qui par défaut au fil du temps
se met à travailler pour le politique et
pour des multinationales
parce que ceux qui sont à l'intérieur
commencent à
préparer leur retraite et leur
reconversion auprès de ces entreprises.
Et là, il y a un problème. Là, ça
correspond pas
au devoir qu'ils ont à respecter à la
base et de se dire voilà le travail
c'est servir le contribuable français
qui paye pour ça la France. Je vous
donne un exemple. Quand
on a la loi renseignement qui se met en
place, on parle de faire des écoutes,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? On va brancher
directement un système d'écoute sur les
câbles des opérateurs France Télécom,
Deutsch Tellcom en Allemagne. On va se
brancher directement sur ce câble. On
pompe toutes vos informations, WhatsApp,
tout ce que vous voulez, tout ce qui est
numérique, vous pouvez changer WhatsApp,
Telegram et tout ça, ça aucune aucune
importance. Tout est pompé.
Tout est lu par un algorithme pour
simplifier les choses. D'accord ? et
l'algorithme, je simplifie parce que
sinon c'est pas compréhensible, mais on
a une communauté très affutée ici.
L'algorithme l'algorithme va déterminer
ce qui peut avec des mots clés et cetera
représenter un intérêt ou pas.
Si c'est chiffré
alors oui, si c'est chiffré, on le
déchiffre. Si vous vous chiffrez de la
vous déchiffrez de la ES 256,
je suis pas je peux pas vous le dire
mais mais on peut déchiffrer et ce qu'il
faut bien savoir c'est que tous les
systèmes de chiffrement ont des bacs
d'or
pour une raison bien naturelle c'est que
s'il y avait pas de bac d'or ser
ça serait interdit et ça poserait un
problème de sécurité majeure à tout le
monde. Bon donc oui il y a des bacs d'or
et quand il y en a pas il faut rentrer
dedans, il faut taper dessus.
Et et quand vous avez d'ailleurs des
petits il y a eu un petit réseau que de
de mafieux qui s'est monté euh où les
gens communiquaient avec leur petits
réseaux cryptés euh entre eux chiffrés,
euh bah il a été démantelé. Mais au bout
d'un moment de toute façon, ça attire
l'attention de tout le monde et et et
puis c'est démantelé. D'ailleurs, plus
vous allez envoyer des fichiers
chiffrés, plus vous allez euh
attirer l'attention parce que ces
fichiersl vont être lus
au travers d'algorithme et vont être on
va essayer de voir pourquoi vous envoyez
des des emails chiffrés, qu'est-ce qui
est si secret pour que voilà. Et donc en
fait, c'est pas une très bonne idée. De
même que envoyer aussi des emails euh
avoir une seule boîte et envoyer un
email dans la zone brouillon de façon à
ce que vous vous puissiez la lire aussi
et que ça reste en brouillon et que ça
soit jamais envoyé, c'est pas une bonne
idée parce que parler de ça
parce que c'est une pratique qu'on voit
souvent
qu'on a vu qu'on a vu
Oui. qu'on a vu qui le Bataclan,
non pas forcément. On l'a vu utilisé par
au départ c'était un des modes de
communication d'Al-Qaïda
et puis c'est comme ça qu'on a détecté
parce que les routeurs font le tour des
boîtes et on voit que la boîte en
question, elle a que du brouillon,
pratiquement que du brouillon et que ce
qui reste ce qui est en brouillon, c'est
ouvert à un endroit et envoyé à un
autre. Donc évidemment ça pose un
problème et et c'est comme ça que ça se
détecte est lu à un autre.
Et lu à un autre. Ouais.
Donc donc comment vous avez été recruté
? Vous êtes venu avec un sandwich, un
jambon beurre
bien sûr. Et vous avez dit "Bonjour les
gars." Bon, je suis en détention de je
détiens de des informations précieuses
pour notre chapelle qui est le la
chapelle bleue blanc rouge
et j'aimerais attirer votre attention où
ils sont venus vous voir parce que vous
étiez dans les salles de marché. Est-ce
que c'est vrai qu'il y a toujours un mec
de la DGSE dans les salles de marché ?
C'est faux.
Non, vraiment c'est faux.
D'abord la si vous voulez la DGSE
s'intéresse à ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur en principe. En principe.
Après, ouais, en principe
les mecs de la DGI d'ailleurs euh sont
de temps en temps
voà maintenant le le voilà l'extérieur
et l'intérieur se croisent quand vous
êtes dans une multinationale bouscule
peut-être
euh vous prenez le cas d' Areva. Areva
était euh statutairement protégé par la
DGSE et la DGSI. Bon,
ce qui est normal,
faire de lance de la France.
Voilà. Voilà, voilà. Absolument. Donc il
y aurait pas dû y avoir de problèmement
de la France.
Absolument. Et donc pour répondre à
votre question, bah comment vous êtes
recruté ? Ça peut être très bien. Le
recrutement, il peut se faire très bien
par la personne qui est concierge dans
cet immeuble euh qui voit des gens
passer euh et on va lui demander bah
voilà euh euh ça nous aiderait en tant
que service français de savoir qui
rentre et qui sort de l'immeuble. Est-ce
que vous pouvez prendre une photo ?
Est-ce que vous pouvez prendre quelque
chose à un moment ou un autre ? parce
que non, un peu d'argent oui, mais on
évite. Vous savez, il y a deux il y a
deux façons qu'il faut éviter pour avoir
de l'information.
La torture est payée. La torture
pourquoi ? Parce que
la personne va vous raconter n'importe
quoi pour que vous arrêtiez. Et donc
l'information est pas fiable.
Pourquoi on a torturé les gens
Guantanamo ?
On torture les gens parce que c'est une
façon rapide d'avoir de l'information.
parce que de toute façon euh bah c'est
dans certains cas euh
voilà c'est une pratique courante et
puis la guerre est un acte absolu. Un
acte absolu, ça n'a pas de limite et
donc bah ça fait partie des pratiques
guerrières.
Euh il y en a pour lesquels c'est
vraiment identitaire. Vous avez des pays
euh toute toute la partie du
Moyen-Orient. Euh c'est une une une zone
géographique où euh la torture fait
partie de de des pratiques courantes.
Euh donc il faut
ça aussi avait une longue tradition de
torture. Non,
ça n'a rien à voir. Pas pas non pas à ce
niveau-là. Moi, j'ai vu en Irak des
concours de torture.
C'est-à-dire vous avez vu
j'avais vu j'ai été témoin de concours
de torture. Ça fait partie des choses
que j'ai que j'ai mis en avant à un
moment.
Qui torturé ? C'était nos amis Kurdes. À
la suite d'un attentat, euh
ils ont arrêté les services Curd ont
arrêté euh deux Arabes.
Ça veut rien dire des Arabes.
Eux ils sont kurdes et la partie adverse
c'était des Arabes sunites.
Euh donc iraakiens arabes sunnites.
Il les arrêtent
et ils les ont mis dans une pièce où il
y avait des crochets de bouché au
plafond.
et ils ont été torturés par des tortures
mutilatoires.
Euh et donc le but du jeu pour le
concours, c'était de d'avoir le maximum
d'information, mais celui qui tuait sa
victime en premier devait payer le resto
aux autres. Euh et donc ça c'est quand
même assez perturbant, même si
auparavant il y a eu cette attentat où
euh qui était très dur euh et où vous
pouvez être ogé dans le sang et on peut
comprendre qui est cette volonté de
cette haine et cette volonté de
revanche. Euh mais euh ça fait partie de
leur culture, vous le retirerez jamais.
quand il y a eu la guerre entre les
Kurdes du Nord et les Kurdes du Sud,
entre eux, ils se sont massacrés, entre
eux, ils se sont torturés. Et moi, j'ai
vu euh un Kurde qui est devenu ministre
après euh qui était médecin de formation
et dont on m'a dit que il maintenait les
torturer en vie le plus longtemps
possible. À l'époque où il était
médecin, il était dans le cur du
Kurdistan du Sud. Euh et donc ça fait
voilà, ça fait partie de
l'environnement. C'est l'environnement
de la guerre aussi. La guerre c'est ça.
Comment un Mzungu arrive dans une salle
de torture ?
Comment hein ?
Comment vous un blanc arrive dans dans
une salle de torture ?
Je peux pas trop donner de détail mais
j'étais dans j'étais proche de ces
gens-là. Moi, j'étais sur une base euh
en fait, j'étais à un endroit qui
s'appelait le château sur les ce qu'on
appelait les rock reports. C'était les
rapports de renseignement qui arrivaient
tous les matins dans le dans l'étatmajor
et américain. Et cette base, elle se
situe pas très loin de Kirkook. C'est
une ancienne forteresse que sa dame
avait fait construire tout le long de la
frontière iranienne
et elle avait été bombardée par les
Américains lors de l'invasion. Euh et
donc tout de la de la de la de la
libération
ou de la libération, l'opération Freedom
en tout cas. Euh et donc cette base,
elle se retrouve bien bombardée, bien
cramée, partiellement détruite, mais
avec l'enceinte qui est toujours solide.
C'est l'intérieur qui était complètement
détruit. Et euh
on n' pas touché à grand-chose avec mon
équipe. On a on a fait en sorte de
trouver deux des pièces de vie qu'on
pouvait aménager
et ça nous arrangeait bien parce que
localement ils avaient peur des
fantômes. Ils ont peur des fantômes. En
fait, il y a une culture aussi de de la
magie dans ces dans ces pays-là ou de de
il y a une partie d'imaginaires. Ils
disent les gens qui ont pas été enterrés
dans le respect de la religion,
ça devient des fantômes. Et donc on
était c'était on était assez tranquille
parce que justement ils avaient peur de
cet endroit-là où les gens étaient bah
ils avaient été cramés sur place quoi.
Et on a pas touché à on les a laissé là
où ils sont et les gravill on les a
laissé là où ils sont et donc ça nous a
donné un peu de paix. À partir de cet
endroit-là, j'ai pu rayonner, j'ai pu
euh faire ce que j'avais à faire et euh
et
malheureusement
les Américains vous ont laissé faire.
Bien sûr. Oui. Le
euh quand vous dites votre équipe, c'est
une équipe de quoi ? C'est des
jardiniers ? C'est des gens qui font des
Non, c'est des dedans, il y avait un
ancien du FBI. Euh, il y avait
des éléments, il y avait un ancien SAS,
il y avait un ancien du deuxème rap, euh
il y avait
J'aime pas le mot
mais bon,
actuel privé, c'est ça ?
Oui, c'est des c'est des militaires
privés. Ouais. Voilà. Combien on les
paye ces gens-là ? Alors, le tarif
aujourd'hui euh pour être en mission que
ça soit de combat ou en mission de
sécurité, de sécurisation,
pour quelqu'un comme moi par exemple,
c'est de l'ordre de 400 dollars la
journée,
euh sachant que la journée c'est fait
24h,
que il y a pas de samedi, pas de
dimanche
et c'est ce qu'on appelle le fuck you
money. C'est-à-dire que
avec ces 400 dollars, on vous les paye
où vous voulez.
Mais vous payez si vous avez une
retraite, vous payez votre retraite,
vous payez votre séc, vous payez ce que
vous voulez. Mais voilà, c'est c'est
brut. Euh après, vous avez les hommes
qui travaillent pour Wagner qui est la
compagnie militaire russe qui est assez
connue, qui fait part des dell pas mal
en Afrique.
Black Black Rock, Blackstone.
Non, non. Alors Black non Black Water et
tout ça c'est autre chose. Wagner Wagner
c'est russe. Wagner vous les voyez en
Centrafrique aujourd'hui vous les voyez
au Mozambique, vous les voyez à
différents endroits. Wagner parce que
c'est des Russes euh ils sont payés 3000
dollars par mois donc beaucoup moins.
Alors que c'est des gens qui ont un
niveau technique assez élevé, très élevé
même, mais c'est la Russie et donc ça
paye beaucoup moins. Mais aujourd'hui,
vous avez vous avez aussi des Népaletis
qui vont être payés à peu près 5000
dollars par mois. Les Gourkaas sont des
bons les Gas sont des bons combattants.
Eux, ils demandent des contrats de 6
mois parce qu'ils vont pas rentrer chez
eux. Donc 6 mois minimum jusqu'à 1 an.
Euh et ils sont payés un petit peu moins
cher, 5 à 6000 dollars par mois. Ils
sont bons mais ils parlent que Népalis.
et ils travaillent qu' eux mais vous ils
peuvent sécuriser une ambassade, ils
peuvent sécuriser vos locaux, il voilà
c'est ça c'est un milieu de gens qui
travaillent pour vivre pour faire vivre
leur famille comme les autres. Les
appelés mercenaires, il y a il y a à peu
près 2 à 3 millions de de mercenaires
peut-être dans le monde.
Quand quand les Fiji utilisent leur
armée pour l'ONU, ils louent
régulièrement l'armée pour l'ONU. Quand
l'Ouganda loue son armée pour des
opérations d'hivers et varié en
Afghanistan ou ailleurs, vous avez des
chefs de gouvernement qui prennent leur
part sur leur salaire et cetera. C'est
la même chose. Sauf que les gars, ils
gagnent pas tout ce qu'il devrait
gagner.
C'est ça aussi qui se passe. Vous avez
des compagnies militaires privées que ça
soit Black Water, ça a changé de nom ça
P X euh mais il y en a il y en a
beaucoup d'autres. Elles essayent de
changer un modèle euh où euh on est dans
le pur muscle pour aller vers un modèle
où on est plus sur le renseignement,
plus sur la valeur ajoutée.
Mais la valeur ajoutée, elle peut pas se
faire si vous avez pas de de
d'exfiltration possible. elle peut pas
se faire si vous avez pas de possibilité
de rester en vie plus de 3 jours. Et
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre quand on
a des opération comme j'en ai eu en
Irak, j'en raconte dans le livre euh une
opération qui qui dure très longtemps.
Qui vous payez ?
Ça, je peux pas vous le dire. Une
combien vous payez ?
Combien c'est en fonction des de la
difficulté de la longueur de l'opération
?
Mais mais c'est rarement un pourcentage
de quelque chose. Donc vous avez une
opération qui va durer longtemps
euh qui va être épuisante et au bout
d'un moment vous avez besoin d'être sûr
qu'à un point donné vous avez une équipe
qui peut venir vous récupérer
et qu'elle et vous avez besoin qu'elle
soit là à leur donner et vous vous devez
être entraîné pour ne pas les mettre en
danger. Donc c'est toute une il y a
toute une symbiose qu'il faut faire pour
que vous vous entraînez avant de cette
opération. Vous il faut que les gars que
qui vont vous chercher, il soi sûr que
vous soyez au point et que vous soyez à
l'heure. Et si vous êtes pas à l'heure,
vous bah vous attendez le prochain
rendez-vous. Et donc il faut avoir une
porte de sortie pour le prochain
rendez-vous. Et donc c'est tout ça. Et
tout ça c'est un travail commun où vous
aurez immancablement besoin de muscles,
de savoir-faire.
et de renseignement et c'est pas
péjoratif de dire de muscle
d'intelligence. Le muscle il est aussi
intelligent parce qu'il va aller vous
chercher et il sait comment vous sortir
de là. Il faut pouvoir compter les uns
sur les autres.
Donc les Américains vous laissent faire
parce que les Américains ont des ont des
droits régaliens en Irak.
Moi, je dirais pas ça. Je dirais qu'
vous avez l'opération, il faut reprendre
l'opération Iraqi Freedom, elle dure 6
mois.
Au bout de 6 mois, vous avez George
Bouge qui va sur un navire militaire et
qui dit
"On a gagné, Saddame est tombé. On voit
la statue de Saddame tomber à Bagdad.
Tout le monde va aller pisser sur sa
tête.
Tout le monde va aller pisser sur la
tête de la statue de Sadame.
Les chiites, les sunnites, tout le
monde.
Soyons clair là-dessus.
L'armée
américaine est libérateur à Bagdad.
Et ça au bout de 6 mois, c'est fini.
George Bouge quand il dit la guerre en
Irak elle est terminée, il a raison à c
à cette à ce moment-là, il a raison.
Après vient la période de la
reconstruction.
La reconstruction.
On parlera on parlera de de du
détournement d'argent sur la
reconstruction de l'Irak un peu après.
Je voudrais qu'on revienne sur la DGSE.
Je vais prendre une question à Internet.
Est-ce que ces témoignages sont une
trahison aux yeux de la DGSE ? Question
de Chuka.
Alors, je crois pas.
Vous savez ce que c'est un Chuka ?
Oui,
c'est un petit oiseau.
Je crois je crois que c'est une trahison
pour
C'est un tank. C'est un tank le chuka.
C'est quoi ? Un avion ? Non. C'est quoi
le choua ?
Il y a eu C'est peut-être un matériel
militaire mais non, pas récent en tout
cas. Mais mais euh
un avion allemand peut-être.
Non, c'est Chetoua.
Ah, vous avez raison. Le le fait est
c'est que il y a des gens à qui
s'appelait pas et ceux à qui s'appelait
pas c'est souvent des gens corrompus.
Moi j'ai moi j'ai pas peur de la justice
de mon pays. Et
il y a des gens corrompus selon vous à
la DGSE.
Oui.
À quel niveau ?
Au niveau des ambassades de de personnes
de personnel qui travaillent au niveau
des ambassades ? C'est sûr, il y a des
choses qui sont impossibles à faire sans
avoir des complicités au niveau des
ambassades
qui sont impossible à faire.
C'est-à-dire,
je pense que
je vous donne un exemple.
En 2014, Areva signe un contrat avec
l'État nigérien.
Alors, précaution oratoire, pas de
diffamation et ainsi de suite.
Areva signe un contrat avec l'État
nigérien en 2014 par lequel il s'engage
à verser un total d'à peu près 110
millions d'euros pour construire un
siège qui servira au ministère des mines
à Niamet.
reconstruire une route, ce qu'on appelle
la route de l'uranium parce que c'est la
route qu'empruntent les camions euh
quand il quand ils vont exporter
l'uranium à partir des mines.
Euh et puis un petit complément pour
développer l'agriculture à un endroit.
Le siège à Niam doit coûter 10 millions
d'euros
en 2014. Quand j'ai quitté en 2020, il
était toujours pas terminé.
Donc tout le monde à l'ambassade peut
voir que l'argent n'est pas allé là.
Tout le monde à l'ambassade peut voir
que l'argent de la route de l'uranium,
elle est pas allée reconstruire la route
de l'uranium.
Tout le monde peut voir que l'argent a
été versé puisque c'est dans les bilans
d'orano
et d'are avant. Tout ça se retrouve. Je
peux vous donner les mentants au
centimes près.
Donc il faut me dire pourquoi quand vous
donner cette information là à la brigade
financière
parce que ça a été fait. Je leur ai dit
voilà ce qui se passe. Vous avez la DRSD
à Niam vous avez la DGSE, vous avez
l'armée, les services militaires, vous
avez le qu d'ors ces gens-là peuvent
constater tous les jours s'il le faut.
que l'argent a été détourné. Ils sont je
vais
Et donc pourquoi pourquoi il n'applique
pas l'article 40 du code de procédure
pénale par lequel on doit appeler le
procureur lui signaler enfin appeler
rédiger un un
constat pour le procureur pour lui faire
constater les faits de façon à ce qu'il
y ait une enquête.
Ils le font pas. Et là, il y a une
réforme que moi j'appelle de tous mes
vœux, c'est de dire bah voilà, que ça
soit pour la DGSI ou la DGSE,
chaque année, on devrait demander au
patron de ces deux services combien de
fois ils ont utilisé l'article 40. Je
leur demande pas le contenu, je leur dis
combien de fois.
C'est pas la même chose.
La corruption, je me fais l'avoquer du
diable. Les ambassades, on les connaît
tous. C'est c'est soit des retours de de
de service qui vont là, ça se passe
bien, tout est cool, on fait des petites
soirées Ferrero Rocher, c'est sympa, on
laisse traîner des oreilles, on fait
style qu'on est là, tout va bien. Ils
ont peut-être autre chose à faire que
ça. Non, non, non, parce qu'on dit au
français, on dit aux français Non, mais
il faut les défendre un peu ces gens-là.
On peut pas quand on est en zone de
guerre, quand on est en zone barcane
et qu'on dit aux français on utilise vos
impôts pour lutter contre le terrorisme,
on utilise vos impôts pour former des
militaires locaux, on utilise vos impôts
pour que ces pays-là n'aient plus
d'immigration, les stabiliser et cetera.
On doit leur rendre des comptes aux
Français.
Barcan 1ARDARD4 en 2019. Elle est où la
Elle est où la corruption là ? Alors,
elle est où la corruption ? C'est que je
vous donne un exemple, vous avez
l'argent notamment au Mali, l'argent des
militaires malien qui est détourné au
Mali.
La solde est détournée par les potentats
du Mali. Mais mais vous êtes témoin de
ça. Vous savez très bien que les soldats
que vous êtes en train de former, ils
ont leur solde qui est détourné. Quand
le Niger émet des faux certificats, des
faux ce qu'on appelle les enduser
certificat pour les armes. D'accord ?
C'est les les certificats de
consommateur final pour une arme. Quand
vous achetez des missiles, vous êtes un
pays, vous dites "OK, moi j'achète des
missiles en l'occurrence des missiles
S8. 916 missiles S8, c'est des missiles
qu'on met sur des hélicoptères russes
notamment.
Le Niger en achète 916 euh sur la base
d'un certificat de user comme quoi il
déclare qu'ils sont les consommateurs
finaux. D'accord ? Ces missiles arrivent
aux portes de Cotonou et au port de
Cotonou, ils disparaissent.
Ça interpelle.
On devrait avoir un communiqué de
Barcane. On devrait avoir madame Parli
qui nous dit quelque chose. Tout ça a
été rendu public. Je peux en parler
parfaitement librement. On a publié tout
ce qui avait à trait par rapport à ce
problème là. Il y a pas eu que les
missiles suite.
Donc ils sont où ? Ils sont partis par
le réseau tout bout en Libye et en
partie au Nigéria. Ils sont où ? Je pose
les jalons, je demande mais moi je suis
contribuable français. Ceux qui nous
regardent le sont peut-être aussi
la corruption la Est-ce que vous avez
des preuves que il y a des mecs à la des
GSE qui touchent des bacchiches ? Est-ce
que vous avez des preuves que il y a des
mecs dans les ambassades qui touchent
des bacchiches ? Des choses comme ça.
Pour pouvoir avoir ces preuves là, pour
pouvoir caractériser le pacte de de
corruption, moi j'ai le fait que
l'argent est pas est pas arrivé au bon
endroit.
Donc mais vous savez pas s'il y a de la
corruption. Alors et et je demande qu'il
y ait des enquêtes et les enquêtes ont
pas lieu. Vous pouvez pas dire qu'il y a
de la corruption.
Alors si c'est pas de la corruption,
qu'est-ce que c'est ? Comment vous
faites ?
De la nonchalance.
C'est de la nonchalance coupable. Ah
c'est c'est pas caractérisé dans le code
pénal. Si peut-être. Non.
Non.
Mais
attention hein, c'est chaque les mots
ont un sens. s'enlever le sens au mot
rajoute de la misère sur le monde.
On est bien d'accord.
Revenons à la DGSE.
Donc vous êtes approché par la DGSE,
vous êtes recruté par votre gardienne,
vous êtes directeur de salle de marché.
Je synthétise ça. Votre agent de
liaison, vous l'avez eu sur le dos
pendant combien de temps ?
3 ans.
Tous les 3 ans, ça change.
Vous avez bénéficié d'une formation
spéciale ? Ils vous ont appris à faire
quoi ? À pas vous faire suivre ? vous
c'est quoi ? Peut-être peut-être parce
que je peux pas répondre à cette
question.
Pourquoi ?
Autant je peux dire qu'un agent de ce
qu'on appelle un officier traitant, tout
le monde en a un euh et que ça on l'a
pendant 3 ans et que ça change au bout
de 3 ans parce que ça c'est connu, c'est
public, il y a pas de souci. Tout ce qui
a trait à ce qui peut être formation,
recrutement,
toutes les particularités de la maison,
ça je peux pas vous en dire plus.
parce que c'est le secret défense.
Et
le secret défense, ça dure combien de
temps maintenant ?
Ah bah
ça ça dure,
ça a été ça a été élargi d'ailleurs il y
a pas très longtemps, il y a moins de 10
ans. Et
vous avez reçu des des
pistes, on vous a demandé de creuser
quoi au départ. C'était dans les salles
de marché, qui investissait où ? Qui
investissait quoi ? Quand quand quand la
DGSE vous voit un petit peu alors vous
aimz vous aimez pas l'expression
bourlinguer en tant que barbouse
mercenaire dans dans dans l'Afrique,
ils vous perçoivent comment ?
Alors
parce que la maison on la on la quitte
jamais. Non,
c'est difficile de quitter ce métier.
Après vous pouvez changer de boutique.
Ouais. Non mais les gens qui changent de
boutique, on les connaît bien.
Non,
vous pouvez vous pouvez avoir à cœur de
faire ce métier-là parce que vous le
trouvez juste, parce que votre
motivation est juste.
Vous aimez le goût du sang ?
Non, parce que vous avez le goût du
combat.
Vous êtes dépendant à l'adrénaline
un peu, ça c'est sûr. Mais mais c'est
pas ce qui vous me motive. C'est c'est
le goût du combat et le goût du combat
juste, ça c'est sûr. Et donc pour ce
combat là, pour arrêter les absurdités
qu'on peut voir comme le financement de
Daesh,
s'il faut travailler avec d'autres
services, des services étrangers y
compris pour obtenir que la punition se
fasse, travailler avec des services que
vous n'aimez pas. Si ça nuit aux
intérêts de la France.
Alors, les intérêts de la France,
qu'est-ce que c'est ? Est-ce que c'est
l'intérêt du contribuable français ?
Est-ce que la DGSE travaille pour
l'intérêt du contribuable français ? Je
suis pas toujours sûr.
J'ai mal croire.
Je suis pas toujours sûr.
La DGS aujourd'hui parce que la
structure de notre constitution est ce
qu'elle est, elle travaille pour le
politique d'abord le chef de l'État et
chef de l'armée.
Ce qui explique aussi que quelqu'un
comme Maxime Réani quand il collecte des
informations parce qu'il est dans un
paradis fiscal à Jersety, qu'il les
donne à la DGSE et que cette information
là est pas utilisée autrement que par
des multinationales qui s'en servent
pour tout à fait autre chose que la
fraude fiscale.
C'est extrêmement préjudiciable.
Extrêmement préjudiciable.
Inacceptable.
Cette formation là, elle aurait dû être
essentiellement utilisée dans l'intérêt
du contribuable français. Donc
comprendre les schémas fiscaux,
récupérer l'argent, euh ce genre de
schéma-là
et arrêter aussi une partie de de mode
de financement du crime organisé puisque
le crime organisé utilise les mêmes flux
offshore que la fraude fiscale. C'est
exactement la même chose avec dans
certains cas les mêmes avocats.
Et donc ne pas faire ça, voir ce qui lui
est arrivé, c'est absolument
inadmissible.
Et ça, beaucoup d'agents me rend me
donneront raison là-dessus. Euh et il y
en a d'autres, je pense à à
agent ou officier, ça dépend.
Quelle importance. Bah l'importance.
Un officier est un agent.
Un agent n'est pas un officier.
Alors, un officier traitant, c'est
quelqu'un qui a la responsabilité de
quelqu'un d'autre. D'accord. Et qui va
travailler comme un comme un cheval
travaille avec son cavalier. Exactement
ça. D'accord. Donc on a tous à un moment
ou à un autre,
sauf que cheval on peut pas le
manipuler.
On lui indique tourne à gauche, tourne à
droite, à quelle vitesse ? On essaie de
le retenir et cetera. Voilà.
Vous montez à cheval ?
Oui, j'ai beaucoup aimé monter à cheval.
Je monte plus mais j'adoré ça. Quel quel
type d'équitation vous ? Le plaisir de
monter à cheval de et de faire de la
randonnée. Donc
fa de la balade quoi.
Oui, tout à fait. Mais c'est mais vous
ça n'empêche pas de monter des bêtes qui
ont du sang parce qu'on a et et quand
vous montez une bête qui a du sang, il
faut pas lui tirer sur la bouche sinon
elle vous dégage.
Non non.
Et ben c'est exactement pareil avec un
homme.
Si vous tirez sur la bouche sans les
jambes, qu'est-ce qui se passe
? Si si vous le serrez trop,
il vous dégage.
À quel niveau ? Au niveau des mains ou
niveau des jambes ?
CL.
Les deux. Il faut absolument il faut
absolument que vous soyez vous ayez un
rapport d'officier traitant, un rapport
de confiance avec votre source et que
votre source soit suffisamment confiante
pour sentir qu'elle est épaulée si ça va
mal. Et en même temps, vous devez avoir
suffisamment de distance
pour pas qu'il y ait d'affect
parce qu'à un moment la relation va se
briser.
Quoi qu'il arrive, il y a un moment il a
la relation va se briser. Mais vous vous
avez quand vous êtes sur une zone comme
l'Irak, le Niger ou le Norivou, peu
importe, vous avez à collecter de
l'information. Vous pouvez pas rien ne
se fait tout seul. Vous êtes bien obligé
d'aller collecter de l'information. Vous
êtes bien obligé de recruter entre
guillemets. Après, vous êtes maître de
ce que vous faites avec votre source. Ça
m'est arrivé d'avoir un un
une source que vous manipulez pour les
intérêts de la DGS.
Manipuler,
c'est une source que vous amenez à
travailler pour vous
et qui va à un moment donné partager la
même idéologie. Je vous donne un
exemple.
Je me trouve en face d'une personne qui
était prof d'université à Bagdad qui me
dit il s'effondre, il me dit voilà moi
j'en ai marre de la vie. Euh je sais
même plus où est ma famille,
je sais même plus s'ils sont en vie
et donc j'ai envie d'en finir.
Tout avant, je te dirais.
Voilà, vous avez résumé résumé la
situation. Effectivement, cette
personne-là cultivée parlant une langue
étrangère que je comprenne ayant encore
un potentiel
devient une source.
Est-ce que c'est dégueulasse d'avoir
fait ça de l'avoir utilisé comme source
?
Est-ce que ça a permis d'avoir des
renseignements qui
permettaient d'avancer dans la mission,
qui permettai de résoudre d'autres
problèmes ? Voilà, c'est comme ça que ça
se passe. Quand vous recrutez une mère
qui vient de perdre son enfant après des
jours d'agonie à l'hôpital de Kirkou et
que cette mère là, elle elle a envie de
se venger, vous recrutez une vraie
bombe. Il y a rien de plus dangereux
qu'une mère de famille qui vient de
perdre son gosse et qui a envie de se
venger parce qu'elle va y aller. Elle
aura peur de rien.
Et ça, il faut bien le comprendre. C'est
ça aussi le travail sur les zones de
guerre. Ça se fait pas derrière la télé,
c'est d'aller sur place, de sentir Moi,
je les vois encore les yeux de ces
femmes-là.
Comment s'appelait ?
Non, je vous donnerai pas d'information
là-dessus, mais on voit on voit
la c'est pas de la haine, c'est la
dureté dans le dans le regard,
l'abandon
et on sait qu'elles sont mortes à
l'intérieur.
Elles sont mortes à l'intérieur. Voilà.
Et après elles veulent se venger bien
sûr et là vous pouvez vous pouvez user,
abuser tout ça, tout ce que vous voulez
mais c'est pas le boulot. Le boulot
c'est d'avoir de de l'utiliser à bon et
de la garder en vie même si elle en a
marre même si elle en veut plus de cette
guerre là.
Et c'est ça qui est terrible. Il faut se
rendre compte que que ça soit sur
l'Afghanistan ou sur l'Irak, ces
guerres-là ont duré extrêmement
longtemps et qu'un gamin qui avait 5 ans
quand Ir Freedom est terminé en 2004,
mais aujourd'hui il a 16 ans de plus. Et
tout ce qu'il a compris ce gamin-là,
c'est que celui qui a l'arme dans la
main, il mange tous les jours, il se
prostitue pas. Celui qui a l'arme dans
la main, c'est celui qui est fort, c'est
celui qui peut se battre. C'est celui
qui peut gagner de l'argent. C'est celui
qui peut prendre l'argent aux autres.
Et c'est comme ça aussi qu' né Daesh et
cetera.
Daesh, moi je les ai vu débuter.
Ils avaient un mode opératoire qui était
assez simple au départ qui était celui
du crime organisé. Il faut il faut se
rendre compte que à l'époque en Irak il
y a pas d'électricité. Il y a il y a
l'électricité, c'est aussi l'eau
courante puisque c'est les pompes pour
les puits euh et donc les gens
fonctionnent avec des générateurs et
donc ils viennent vous voir et vous
dites "Bah voilà, si tu me donnes pas
quelques diram euh bah je fais sauter
ton générateur. Bon et au bout d'un
moment ça fait déjà un peu d'argent et
puis il y a les enlèvements. pour pour
enlever quelqu'un d'intéressant, mais on
va voir quelqu'un qui travaille dans une
banque d'abord et on dit "Bah toi, tu as
accès au compte, donc tu nous dis qu'il
y a de l'argent sur le compte et on va
enlever la personne qui a de l'argent
sur le compte et on sait exactement
combien demander et donc ils ont
infiltré les banques
et petit à petit, ils sont devenus de
plus en plus puissants. Quand il y a des
opérateurs télécomer
un réseau GSM, c'est des antennes
simples.
Donc je protège le générateur et
l'antenne. Donc faut me donner de
l'argent.
Et les opérateurs télécoms ont payé. Et
c'est comme ça petit à petit qu'on a eu
d'abord Isil, ça s'appelait Isil et
après ISIS et DH. Voilà. Enfin, on a eu
une formation forte.
Revenons revenons à nos moutons.
Donc on vous recrute,
vous êtes formé,
ils vous ont criblé avant.
Oui.
Comment ? Jusqu'à où ? Jusque loin.
Vous devez vous devez vous assurer que
la personne que vous allez recruter,
ça veut dire cribler
euh mettre à poil,
aller jusqu'à s'intéresser à la famille,
jusqu'aux enfants, jusqu'aux enfants à
l'école,
tout.
Tout
d'abord parce que vous devez ôter d'un
doute, vous vous dire "Est-ce que je
suis pas en train de recruter quelqu'un
qui travaille pour l'adversaire ?
Ça c'est la première chose dont il faut
s'assurer. Bon après la motivation. Donc
on va vous dire bah les motivations ça
peut être ça peut être l'idéologie, ça
peut être l'argent, ça peut être l'amour
entre guillemets.
Ça peut voilà en fait
c'est simpliste.
Le monde est pas si tranché que ça. Vous
pouvez très bien avoir de de l'amour
pour quelqu'un et être recruté
euh par amour. euh mais aussi faire
enfin ça peut correspondre à votre
idéologie. Il y a eu des opérations
Roméo où on a recruté enfin pas la
France mais c'était l'Allemagne de l'Est
qui les a faites euh c'était Marcus Volt
qui qui les a monté où il a recruté euh
des femmes. C'était brillant comme
opération.
Il a recruté euh
des femmes qui étaient dans des écoles
de secrétariat à une époque où elles
devait travailler dans l'administration
ces femmes-là après leurs études. Et
donc il avait compris que elles allaient
être en tant que secrétaire proche de
fonctionnaires haut placés et que elle
pourrait récupérer des informations.
Donc il fallait avoir un sacré
raisonnement. Il fallait prévoir sur
plusieurs années ce que ça pouvait
donner. avoir le budget.
Oui, mais la l'Allemagne de l'Est, c'est
comme le KGB, ils avaient un budget
limité. Donc et euh ils a fait ce qu'on
appelle les opérations Roméo,
c'est-à-dire qu'il a fait en sorte que
ces femmes-là soient draguées par des
hommes. Certains ont même épousé leur
cible. Ils avaient deux mariages, leur
vie à côté et leur vie voilà. Et ça a
duré jusqu'à la chute du mur de Berlin.
Puis après, elles sont envolées.
Ah bah après ça ça a mal tourné.
Voilà. Voilà. parce que les femmes
c'est ça qu'on les appelle les
irondelles.
Non, les femmes se sont retrouvées
toutes seules euh et puis certaines ont
fait de la prison parce qu'elles avaient
collaboré avec la Stasie euh
de l'ordre de 3 ans euh et puis et
surtout elles se sont effondrées parce
qu'elles ont compris qu'elles avaient
été recrutées
et beaucoup enfin quasiment toutes ont
pas saisi qu'elles étaient en train de
travailler pour la Stasie et que voilà.
Donc c'est le genre de chose qui peut se
passer dans ce milieulà qui n'a mais
c'est encore une fois on est sur
encore ça
bien sûr
ça se fait où ?
Bon ça se fait
à Cuba.
Bon Cuba c'est petit. Enfin ça
il sont bon les services Cubains ? Non
non non franchement non. Enfin c'est pas
c'est pas les les services qui sont
bons. Je dirais en haut de la liste
incontestablement Israël.
En deuxème les Russes parce que ils ont
une histoire parce que c'est dans leur
c'est dans leur veine, c'est dans leur
sens, c'est dans leur c'est dans leur
histoire euh et ils ont un budget
limité.
Euh après, vous avez les États-Unis
évidemment et puis après c'est très en
dessous. Euh vous avez les services
chinois, après tout est question de
budget.
On est où la France ?
On n'est pas sur le radar. Quand je vous
entends parler, j'ai l'impression que
vous idéalisez un petit peu les services
américains et israéli.
Non, idéalisé non. J'ai la
reconnaissance,
je sais ce qu'il faut pour arriver à
faire certaines opérations. Le sens du
sacrifice et c'est les services
israéliens. L'avantage qu'ils ont par
rapport à nous, c'est qu'ils ont une
mission qui est parfaitement définie.
Parfaitement définie.
Qui est la défense d'Israël par tous les
moyens ?
Sachant qu'Israël est régulièrement en
guerre. Donc il ils se considèrent
constamment en temps de guerre et leur
mission c'est la mission stratégique de
préserver les intérêts d'Israël et les
Israéliens. Voilà, c'est extrêmement
clair. Et
et la France, c'est quoi ? Et donc, vous
ne verrez pas Israël intervenir dans un
conflit comme nous on peut le faire et
cetera pour des histoires de pognons,
des choses comme ça. Non, la défense
d'Israël, Israël c'est un petit pays, 8
à 9 millions d'habitants, hein. Donc
voilà, qui n'a pas de ressources
naturelles, c'est que du jus de cervel.
Ça ne vit que des que des entreprises
israéliennes. Ils ont un peu de gaz
devant chez eux quand même.
Bon, c'est peu de choses, c'est vraiment
c'est c'est ça. Pas de ressources
naturelles en Israël.
Donc oui, il y a là, il y a un respect
parce que je sais ce que ça représente
comme travail. Ça m'empêche pas aussi de
respecter. Je suis je suis pas pro russe
mais je respecte quand même le travail
qui a été fait par les agents d'octobre
rouge pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
qui ont changé le cours de la seconde
guerre mondiale. On peut leur leur
rendre cet hommage.
Quand vous voyez quand vous voyez des
des agents du grou du grou
Ouais. Gru
se faire serrer euh vers la Savoie.
Juste avant
même à côté de chez moi en haut de
savoir. Ouais.
Oui. Bien sûr. Tout tous les savoyards
savaient qu'il y avait des Ruskovs qui
se baladaient là-bas. Non
non.
Oh là là
non mais on sait que on sait que la
Suisse est une on sait que la Suisse est
une plateforme importante de la Russie.
un hub aérien. Ouais, un un enfin un
hub, c'est euh
on c'est c'est quasiment une euh un
terrain de j'allais dire d'entraînement
comme l' France d'ailleurs
mais et ils ont parfaitement infiltré
comme les la France
parce que les Russes ne craignent rien
de du contreespionnage français parce
qu'il a pas les moyens que la DGSI peut
rien faire ou peu de choses Ils ont
débossé quand même. Il ils ont balancé
les rues juste avant la la visite de
Poutine en France. C'est quand même un
crochepad qui était euh
c'est c'est peu de choses par rapport
aux moyens que les Russes peuvent
déployer parce qu'ils en font. C'est
c'est une activité nationale pour eux.
C'est des budgets illimités. Euh on
parle les services russes, ça
représente, on va dire 350000 personnes.
Bon euh combien d'opé
la DGSE euh même aujourd'hui peut-être
allez peut-être la DGSE et encore
qu'est-ce qu'on compte les contractuels
ou pas ? Mais on va dire allez pour être
gentil 5 à 5 à 6000 personnes après tous
des efforts, bon on peut pas on peut pas
lutter. D'accord. C'est c'est comme si
on comparait le travail de des services
français avec le travail des services
américains et et leur 17 agences si on
compte celle qui renseigne le le
président américain. Donc euh bon
euh il y a un moment où on peut pas se
battre sur le même sur le même niveau
euh tant sur le plan de la technologie
que sur le plan des hommes.
Il faut admettre ça. Mais encore une
fois, pourquoi on ne se contente pas de
défendre simplement les intérêts de la
France et des Français ?
Ça serait déjà tellement bien.
Est-ce qu'on défend les intérêts de la
France et des Français en allant en
Centrafrique ? Moi, je suis pas sûr.
On défend les intérêts de
Vous êtes expert comptable. C'est pas
Alors
voilà, moi je suis pas sûr du tout quand
on fait l' 7 ans de barcane sans aucun
résultat, est-ce qu'on peut prétendre
défendre la France et les Français alors
qu'on a mis le bordel en Libye et qu'on
n'est pas capable de et qu'on et que que
cette Libye, elle souffre encore de de
tous ces mots et et que ça peut durer
encore des années.
Est-ce qu'il fallait pas simplement ne
pas s'emmêler ? Simplement.
Il fallait qu'on apporte les écoles pour
les petites filles quand même.
Oui, bien sûr.
C'est important.
On fait de l'humanitaire
toujours.
B toujours. Voilà. C'est de
l'humanitaire qui coûte très cher.
L'humanitaire de la France-Afrique ne
concerne que très peu de gens. Très peu
de gens. D'accord. Et ça coûte un
maximum à la population française. Et ça
off. Ça il faut s'arrêter.
Donc vous avez été recruté, ils vous ont
formé,
euh ils vous ont demandé d'exfiltrer de
l'information depuis les salles de
marché ou ils vous ont demandé ils vous
ont demandé quoi avant que vous vous
soyez contractuel pour une agence privée
?
Ils m'ont demandé, je peux pas trop
parler d'émission parce qu'il y a des
gens qui sont toujours vivants. Euh et
puis euh ça concerne des pays étrangers,
donc c'est pas simple d'en parler. Euh
mais vous êtes dans un une période de
temps où bah vous avez à la fois des
activités de guerre et vous avez
Attendez, il vient ils vous font venir
chez Mortier, ils vous font quoi ?
Je peux pas en parler.
Il vous fil dans un café.
Ils vous font passer un petit mot dans
un bouquet de fleurs.
C'est disons que il y a pas de
d'activité une petite message sur votre
monde connecté.
Non non. Alors il y a il y a rien de
très particulier. Il y a des prudences.
Comment
cétait faire un itinéraire de sécurité
avant d'aller à un endroit ?
C'est-à-dire de vérifier que vous n'êtes
pas suivi. Bah ça ça vous protège vous
et ça vous protège votre
connecté.
Non, bah vous êtes pas de la DGS.
Je ne vous n'avez pas le pire de ce qui
peut vous arriver, c'est d'être arrêté
en possession de matériel
qui va automatiquement vous dénoncer.
Je vous donne un exemple. Vous avez un
ordinateur et vous vous dites "Ah bah
moi je vais protéger mon ordinateur, les
informations
de qui ? de ce que vous voulez, même des
hackurs. Euh, je vais le protéger en
utilisant euh Tro Crypt. Bon, peu
importe, je suis pas spécialiste.
Et donc, vous avez Tro Crypt,
la version bac d'oré ou la version
normale ?
La version normale et vous passez une
frontière et ça se passe mal. Vous êtes
arrêté, on vous demande vos codes
d'accès à l'ordinateur. Bon, déjà, si
vous les donnez pas, vous allez prendre
quelques claques. Donc, au bout d'un
moment, vous en avez marre, vous les
donnez.
Vous aurez un agent qui va regarder ce
que vous avez. Vous avez troupt.
Pourquoi vous avez Trou Crypt ? C'est
pour maîtresse.
Pourquoi en plus de Trou Crypt vous avez
un logiciel de cryptage de chiffrage ?
Ah
pourquoi vous avez Ta ? Voilà pourquoi
vous alors ah vous pouvez toujours
bredouiller hein, vous pouvez toujours
dire euh voilà mais vous êtes en
position d'être soupçonné de faire du
renseignement pour une agence étrangère.
Que ça soit vrai ou que ça soit faux, ça
va mal se finir.
Donc
c'était dans quel pays
c'était dans quel pays ça ?
Ah bah ça ça peut se passer dans
beaucoup de pays notamment au
Moyen-Orient. Je ça c'est
Moyen-Orient
l'enfer. vous passez une frontière avec
du matériel qui
est suspect
euh vous allez avoir des problème tout
de suite.
Et donc c'est le genre de chose qu'il
faut pas faire et donc il faut apprendre
à passer une frontière avec
des renseignements si vous en avez, si
vous avez des photos à ramener et tout
ça, bah faire attention à ce que ça soit
pas justement aussi visible que ces
choses-là.
Et il faut le mieux étant de
communiquer. Vous savez très bien que
votre information va être captée mais
elle est capté par les bonnes personnes.
Elle est captée par des services alliés.
Donc oui, l'information est captée. Oui.
Et alors ?
Au final,
vous avez donné l'information
à un service allié. C'est bon.
On n pas d'alliés.
Moi j'en ai.
Oui, mais vous êtes alors vous
travaillez pas
moi dans mes combats, j'en ai. C'est ça.
Quand vous avez euh quand
je vous entends parler, en fait quand je
vous entends parler, j'ai l'impression
d'entendre une ancienne source de la
DGSE qui est tellement euh
qui a un goût aigre dans la bouche et
qui préfère bosser pour des puissances
entre guillemets alliées plutôt que de
bosser pour sa patrie et son drapeau.
Je pourrais bosser pour ma patrie et mon
drapeau le jour où la patrie et le
drapeau fera le ménage et que les
personnes qui sont corrompues, les
personnes qui posent un problème seront
tradu voilà que je pense corrompu seront
traduits en justice.
Je suis en contact avec des services du
ministère de l'intérieur. Je leur amène
des dossiers
régulièrement. J'ai communiqué aussi
avec les procureurs italiens en ce qui
concernait le le financement de de
Daesh. J'ai confiance dans le fait que
les procureurs italiens vont lire ce que
je leur ai donné, ils vont le prendre en
compte et ils vont faire avancer leur
enquête. En France, pourquoi j'ai un
doute ? Je suis français, je donne au
service du ministère de l'intérieur.
Pourquoi j'ai un doute ? Pourquoi quand
la députée Frédéric Duma pose la
question du financement de Daesh à
monsieur Castaner cet été ?
Une question écrite à un membre du
gouvernement ministre de l'intérieur en
poste il a jamais répondu.
Pourquoi quand elle remet le couvert
qu'elle pose la question à Jean-Ive
Lodrian en commission des affaires
étrangères,
il botte en touche ?
Et ça c'est dans mon pays. Donc quand ça
changera dans mon pays, je veux bien
considérer le fait qu'il faut travailler
que avec mon pays. Mais tant que c'est
pas le cas, l'information qui permet de
pénaliser, qui permet d'envoyer ces gens
en prison, cette information là, il faut
la donner aux gens qui peuvent les
envoyer en prison.
Est-ce que vous pensez que la DGS vous
prend pour un collabo qui bosse avec des
puissances étrangères ?
Ça m'est égal.
Eux, ils ont leur vision, ils obéissent
aux ordres qu'ils reçoivent.
Je leur souhaite de pas je leur souhaite
de pas oublier que c'est le contribuable
qui les paye et qu'il faut et qu'il faut
se rappeler qu'on a on a un devoir
vis-à-vis des Français et que les
Français sont prioritaires par rapport
au monde politique. Ils ne travaillent
pas pour un ministre, ils rendent des
comptes à un ministre. C'est pas tout à
fait la même chose.
Est-ce que alors question d'internet,
est-ce que vous avez été manipulé ?
Euh non, j'ai pas l'impression. Sinon
que on m'a peut-être pas tout dit
lorsqueon m'a déclenché certaines
missions. Allez, je vous donne un
exemple. quand le l'amiral d'Arbonau
qui était un homme brillant euh qui
était responsable de la défense de la
force nucléaire française me donne la
mission de le mandat concernant
l'affaire uramine et les affaires
attendez il vous donne la mission
la mission de d'enquêter sur l'affaire
uramine
d'accord mais vous étiez quoi ou
ah bah lui il était responsable de la
sécurité et de du patrimoine chez Areva
c'était son titre directeur de la
sécurité du patrimoine cheva militaire
Il était amiral en retraite
donc P
alors oui toujours
il était toujours lié à son au ministère
de la défense par sa fonction du fait
aussi que Areva était une société
publique à capitaux d'état public donc
il était plus militaire de carrière
amiral en poste dans la dans la marine
mais il avait toujours ses contacts au
niveau du ministère de la défense.
Et donc euh il me donne cette mission.
Je suis pas sûr. Rencontré,
je peux pas vous le dire
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
une petite annonce on vous connaît sur
la place publique.
Non. Voilà. Ouais. C'est quoi votre
c'est quoi votre surnom ?
J'ai pas de surnom. J'ai pas de surnom.
Mais euh
la le le recrutement, il était fait
parce qu'il y a peu de gens qui
pouvaient aller euh faire ce qu'il me
demandait rapidement. Et euh il m'avait
demandé aussi une mission de terrain en
Centrafrique justement à un moment où la
Lera avait envahi une zone. La Lera
c'est la Lord Resistance Army qui était
dirigée par un dingue qui s'appelait
Joseph Conny euh et euh des gens qui
massacraient la population locale. Ils
avaient
ils étaient allés ils étaient descendus
jusqu'en Centrafrique sur la zone qui
était
la zone de sur lequelle Areva voulait
travailler et donc il voulait demander
ce qu'il en était. Euh et donc fallait
monter une mission pour aller voir sur
place ce qu'il en était et la mission a
pas eu lieu. Mais euh
de toute façon donc il m'avait missionné
pour la feramine et je pense que
avec Joseph Con là ça c'était
c'était 2010
précisément c'est Joseph Conis et mars
2010.
mars 2010, Joseph Coni, Centrafrique.
C'était même à
cette époque-là, euh
Joseph Coni avait quitté le Norquivou
pour remonter en Centrafrique. Le Nord
Kivou, moi je connaissais bien et euh
et après il est il est allé encore plus
haut. Mais bon, voilà. Il y a pas eu
d'intoxication autour de de Coni là,
c'est-à-dire de l'intoxication ?
Ouais, je m'en rappelle plus. Ça c'est
un mot je demanderai à la communauté de
checker, mais euh on avait pas utilisé
sa tête pour euh
Non, non, non. On avait il y avait un
prix sur sa tête
qui était justifié. Euh Joseph Conny,
c'était quelqu'un de particulier, si on
fait un petit aparté, c'est que il
utilisait pas de téléphone parce qu'il
disait "Moi, j'ai pas besoin de
téléphone, je parle direct avec le
Seigneur. Je suis en ligne directe avec
le Seigneur." Bon euh c'est pour ça
qu'il appelait son groupe la Lord
Resistance Army. Et puis euh c'était une
sorte de secte et quand il débarquait
dans des villages, il attrapait des
femmes et il coupait les joues ici,
cette partie-là de la joue pour faire un
sourire permanent.
Donc on avait des femmes qui étaient
mutilées qui dont on voyait les
un peu comme les nationalistes les
suprémastistes blancs. Non
non, j'ai pas eu enfin mais donc
c'était sa marque de fabrique on va dire
et ce type là a sév pendant des années.
Je pense pas qu'il soit mort. J'ai pas
suivi où il en était mais il y a eu
différentes missions qui ont été montées
euh pour le débusquer et le tuer. Et je
crois pas que ça soit terminé. Je crois
pas qu'il soit mort. Il est quelque part
en haut d'une montagne où mais il a il a
plus le la nuisance qu'il avait avant.
Donc
revenons à feu feu euh mon amiral.
Donc il vous dit les gens là-bas en tant
que privé.
Ouais.
Il ne fait il ne demande pas à la DGSE
voilà
de d'y aller. Pourquoi ?
parce que euh je pense qu'il avait
compris euh l'importance de l'affaire,
l'importance politique qui entourer
cette affaire-là et il s'est dit "Je
peux pas leur demander
de travailler là-dessus, ça ira dans une
impasse, il y aura pas de sortie, il va
rien se passer." Et quand l'affaire
Uramine a eu lieu, quand l'OPA sur
Uramine a eu lieu, on lui avait demandé
de regarder ailleurs. Donc déjà, il
avait eu des prémisses à ce niveau-là.
Parce qu'il me l'avait dit.
et euh confirmé.
Ah bah il est mort maintenant. Mais mais
on est resté en contact pendant très
longtemps euh bah jusqu'à sa mort et
quelqu'un qui c'était quelqu'un qui
était très droit, lui qui était un vrai
serviteur de l'État et je comprends
qu'on lui a confié les sous-marins
nucléaires, la toute cette partie-là qui
était extrêmement stratégique
parce que c'était un vrai serviteur de
l'État. ilait jamais rien lâché.
C'était quelqu'un de bien.
Donc revenons à la DGSE. Donc ils vous
ont recruté, ils vous ont envoyé en
opération. Vous étiez rémunérés comment
?
De façon euh
périodique, on va dire. Voilà.
Combien ?
Je peux pas vous le dire.
Ni Non, non, ça je peux pas. ni comment
ni combien parce que ça peut gêner
d'autres opérations, d'autres personnes
et cetera et mais bon vous ne faites pas
fortune en faisant ce métier-là.
Vous faites fortune après quand vous
êtes privé et que vous travaillez euh
que vous montez votre propre agence
comme Croll l'a fait, comme d'autres
l'ont fait euh et que vous avez des
contrats d'état, c'est souvent des
contrats pour pour les grosses agences,
des contrats qui viennent de la CIA ou
du M6. Euh là oui euh
vous faites le un peu le boulot que eux
ne peuvent pas faire directement parce
que ça poserait des problèmes euh et
puis parce que vous avez des compétences
très précises qui n'ont plus ou pas à un
moment donné euh et que vous avez
développé localement sur place. Euh
si on me donnait quelque chose à faire
au Soudan, au Soudan, je vois tout de
suite à qui je m'adresse. Euh je
pourrais pas vous le dire, non pas au
Chinois,
je vois tout de suite à qui je
m'adresse. Euh voilà, des choses comme
ça. Vous vous pouvez aller très vite
si vous êtes dans un système qui est
déjà une agence qui donne qui rend des
comptes publics, c'est plus lourd.
La mission, vous la montez pas aussi
rapidement.
Euh jusqu'ici tout va bien. H et
comment vous faites pour vous protéger ?
Bah en publiant,
tout ce que j'ai euh
écrit dans le livre et parti et en gros
oui, pratiquement tout a été euh publié
dans la presse, pas dans les mêmes
détails. Euh il y a beaucoup plus dans
le livre, mais des affaires comme
l'affaire OSRA a été publiée avant
d'être dans le livre. Euh
et en étant en contact avec euh des
personnes du ministère de l'intérieur
qui suivent en étant en contact avec euh
des services étrangers qui suivent aussi
euh qui ont les mêmes intérêts, qui ont
les mêmes envies de justice.
Voilà, donc ça empêchera pas de se faire
tuer. Mais au moins si vous voyez cette
blogueuse maltaise qui a été tuée GZ là,
la bonne nouvelle c'est que son
commanditaire a avoué cette semaine, la
semaine dernière moin
et
cette femme-là travaillait pour le FBI.
Euh
je crois que au travers de la mort, elle
a gagné son combat
parce que depuis qu'elle a été tuée, il
y a une machinerie énorme qui s'est mis
en route qui a permis de démonter
énormément de réseaux Mathieu à Malte
jusqu'au Premier ministre Maltais,
que tous ces gens-là ont leurs avoir
bloqués, sont en prison pour certains ou
vont être jugés pour d'autres et cetera.
Et voilà, c'est c'est la récompense
qu'elle peut avoir dans la mort.
C'est ce que vous attendez.
Si ça m'arrive, c'est pas voilà, c'est
pas un regret. Pas de regret. Moi, j'ai
une vie extraordinaire.
Ça leur fait peur les gens comme vous.
Non.
Oui, parce qu'on n pas de
Ouais,
ça voilà, ça peut se passer dans une
heure, c'est pas un problème. Et je sais
que si ça se passe dans une heure, il y
aura du monde pour s'en occuper.
Occuper, c'est
c'estàd qu' aura voilà, il y aura du
monde qui va venir chercher pourquoi et
qui va aller jusqu'au bout et qui va
reprendre tout ce que j'ai laissé et qui
va reprendre et qui ira jusqu'au bout.
Ça les meilleur des assurances.
Oui, mais c'est aussi
sympa de se dire il y a des gens qui
pensent comme vous, il y a des gens qui
veulent se battre pour les mêmes
raisons, euh qui sont qui ont pas le
même drapeau, qui ont pas la même
histoire, qui ont pas la même culture et
qui pourtant vont se retrouver à un
endroit, c'est un peu le cercle rouge,
hein, qui vont se retrouver à un endroit
pour aller vers le même combat. Voilà.
Euh on
et vous avez vous avez pas idée à quel
point les agents qui soient français ou
autres d'ailleurs euh certains agents
peuvent avoir le sens du sacrifice.
Moi j'ai vu notamment il y a il y a une
mission qui est connue point
jusqu'au bout. Euh je vous donne un
exemple qui s'est passé en Syrie avec
euh un agent russe militaire mais russe,
un agent russe euh qui était euh chargé
de euh
déterminer exactement où se trouvaient
les positions de de Daesh en Syrie à un
endroit précis. Bon et puis il s'est vu
encerclé.
Il alors non, il a demandé à son
aviation de le bombarder lui,
d'aller jusqu'au bout et de dire "OK, je
me laisse encerclé,
c'est pour vous les gars,
c'est pour vous les gars, allez-y.
Chapeau. Faut avoir le courage de faire
ça,
c'est pas évident du tout. SPNAS.
Ouais. Et et quand vous êtes dans il
faut voir la dureté de ces zones là, la
dureté des
Vous en connaissez des Spas ?
Euh non, pas d' spè NAS, non. J'ai
travaillé avec des SAS, avec des
réquises Sud-Africains,
avec le 2è RP, des gens du 2è rep, des
des GCP, des groupements commando
parachutistes. Euh
voilà, c'est mais vous avez dans les
forces spéciales, ce qu'on appelle
spécial, elle n'ont de spécial que deux
choses, la détermination absolue
et le matériel,
l'entraînement.
Je dirais que vous pouvez l'avoir
l'entraînement, vous pouvez l'avoir. Il
apporte si vous avez la capacité
physique, l'entraînement vous pouvez
l'avoir. Mais la détermination au
combat, c'est la clé. C'est 90 % de
votre travail. C'est la détermination au
combat.
C'est comme en boxe. Vous pouvez être
excellent techniquement si vous n'êtes
pas déterminé au moment du combat, c'est
même pas la peine.
Question internet. Est-ce que vous avez
un background dans les arts martiaux ?
Oui. Lourd. Ouais. Ouais. Ouais.
judo euh travaille avec des armes
blanches euh et j'enseigne aujourd'hui
la box taille et j'ai pratiquer la box
très longtemps mais j'enseigne encore la
box et je combat encore tout
régulièrement. Bon c'est voilà
c'est quelqu'un qui vous connaît ça
possible.
Donc vous étiez au tout départ dans les
salles de marché
vous avez attaqué la banque de Londres
c'est ça la banque
Alors j'ai pas attaqué la Banque de
Londres. Il y a eu une un mouvement
spéculatif contre la Banque
d'Angleterre. La
livre.
Voilà. Contre la livre. Euh de mémoire
c'est 90. Étiez pas le seul. Non.
Alors on éétait pas le seul. C'est
l'époque où George Soros quelle banque ?
C'est l'époque où Moi, j'étais à la
Mitsubishi banque et c'est l'époque où
George Soros euh monte son fond quantum
avec un gars qui s'appelle Mary Weather
qui était son bras droit. Euh et il fed
de l'énergie, il fédère des salles des
marchés autour d'eux. et on calcule
combien de quelle puissance on peut
avoir euh à ce moment-là par rapport à
la Banque d'Angleterre qui a des
réserves bien déterminé et qui est la
Banque d'Angleterre, ça reste des
fonctionnaires et donc des
fonctionnaires, ils travaillent de
certains ils arrivent le matin à 8h, à
5h, ils s'en vont. Ce qui se passe après
5h à l'époque voilà, c'est plus leurs
problèmes. Et donc évidemment le gros de
la taxe se construit la nuit quand ils
sont pas là. Après, ils apprendront à
passer des ordres de nuit et cetera,
faire des permanences et tout ça. Mais
tout ça euh pour vous dire que on va
avoir euh un potentiel euh de munition
beaucoup plus important que celui de la
Banque d'Angleterre avec ses réserves de
changé, c'est ça. Et donc,
elle va se faire écraser et la banque et
la livre va dévaluer et c'est comme ça
avec d'autres. Ça sera pareil en
Thaïlande avec le ta bat.
Alors, pourquoi on arrive à faire ça ?
Et ça, je l'explique dans un livre qui
s'appelle la machine spéculative parce
qu'à un moment il y a un déséquilibre
fort entre le message politique où on
vous dit "Oui, mais on fait de la dette
mais ça pose pas de problème." "Oui,
mais on a des résultats économiques
alors que il y a de l'inflation. Oui,
mais on a ceci. Oui, mais on a cela."
Donc le discours est politique, voter
pour moi, tout va bien. Et la réalité et
quand ça se décale de trop, quand le la
réalité ne correspond plus du tout à la
fiction que le politiqu est en train de
vous vendre alors qu'il est au pouvoir,
à ce moment-là, il y a un rééquilibrage
et c'est violent.
Donc quand on vous dit en France oui, on
en est à 120 % du PIB, c'est deux fois
le critère de Masric mais vous inquiétez
pas, dormir tranquille, il se passera
rien. On vous prend pour des imbéciles
et oui, il y aura un retour de bâton
très sévère. Oui, ça sera comme la
Grèce, ça sera comme Chypre. Oui, vous
connaîtrez ça, vos enfants connaîtront
ça.
Faut que ça soit clair quand ça va se
déclencher ? C'est c'est l'histoire du
baril de poudre avec l'étincelle.
Donc là, vous êtes en train de dire que
la dette française va se faire attaquer
par des fonds vautour et ça va nous
emmener du sang et des larmes dans les
rues.
Ah mais la dette française c'est une
bombe à retardement.
Donc c'est juste une question de temps.
Et vous avez toujours des gens pour vous
dire c'est pas la c'est pas grave, on la
repayera pas. Ah bah allez voir les
Grecs.
Eux ils ont pas compris. Alors il y a un
petit problème là.
Allez voir la réalité de ce qui s'est
passé
quand vous avez à manger le lundi et
queon vous dit bah le lendemain, le
mardi vous avez plus qu'un quart dans
votre assiette.
En gros, un/art sur votre compte en
banque.
Oui. C'est ce qui s'est passé avec
Chypre.
avec Chypre du jour au lendemain, on a
bloqué les comptes bancaires des
Cypriotes
et des Russes.
Non, les Russes ils ont pu pas tous
beaucoup ils ont eu peur pour ça. Mais
les chipriotes, on leur a dit "Bah,
voyez vos économies, c'est fini. Vous
avez plus de 100000 dollars ou euros,
c'est fini. Le reste c'est fini.
Dur.
Il faudra pas compter sur le fond de
garantie des téu bancaires s'il y a des
banques qui calanchent." C'est ça. Bah
alors euh déjà il y en aura pas pour
tout le monde hein. Mais euh
mais euh
d'autres pays européens, je on peut
citer l'Allemagne, l'Allemagne a réussi
avec Merkel à rééquilibrer ses budgets,
a réussi à à diminuer sa dette. Elle a
fait beaucoup de choses, Merkel, et
c'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle mouti.
Euh, il y a il y a un vrai sentiment
d'une femme qui a qui a tout fait pour
son pays.
Euh, on aurait bien Moi, je je Est-ce
que j'aurais voulu une Merkel en France
? Mais tout de suite, je signe.
Voyez, même si elle parle allemand, pas
de problème. Si elle peut faire la même
chose que ce qu'elle a fait en
Allemagne, je signe tout de suite.
Mais nous, on a continué à nous mentir.
On a continué à émettre de la dette
publique. On a on a des années sans
interruption de déficit public, mais ça
devient ça devient Est-ce que des
enfants aujourd'hui peuvent concevoir
qu'un jour on a eu un un état avec un un
budget à l'équilibre ? hein, il faut
avoir quel âge pour ça ? Moi, j'ai 58
ans, ça je me souviens que dans les
années 70, on a eu un moment des budgets
en équilibre. Faut remonter à ces
années-là.
Mais des gens de votre génération, un
budget, bah c'est un déficit.
C'est quoi ? C'est de la subordination
de vote.
C'est de la tromperie.
On fait croire aux gens que ça peut
toujours durer. On fait croire aux gens
qu'on peut faire aucune réforme, que ça
peut continuer comme ça, qu'on peut
dépenser 1 milliard et demi par an pour
du barcane parce que c'est une priorité
que quelqu'un a décidé alors qu'en fait
les priorités elles sont là. Vous êtes
en France, les priorités elles sont chez
vous, elles sont là.
Qu'est-ce que ça fait d'attaquer une
banque centrale
en sachant que derrière
ça donne ça donne
c'était la première fois qu'une banque
centrale perdait et ça ça a été un des
éléments déclencheurs de la zone euro
parce que sinon toutes les monnaes il
seraient passé et
c'est sûr que ça donne un il y a un
sentiment de puissance. Ouais, ça c'est
la puissance qu'on pouvait avoir à cette
époque-là où il y avait pas beaucoup, il
y avait pas du tout les mêmes contrôles
qu'aujourd'hui, hein. Euh,
c'était phénoménal. Rendez-vous compte
qu'après l'opération sur la Banque
d'Angleterre,
pour rentrer dans le fond quantum de de
George Sorose pour pour juste lui donner
votre argent, votre épargne à gérer, il
fallait payer 30 % de droit d'entrée.
Donc vous lui donniez 100 € il fallait
lui, il prenait 30 €. de frais d'entrée.
Donc il ne gérait que 70
et les gens abondaient
la folie. Et c'était l'homme qui a fait
c'est l'homme qui a fait tomber la bande
d'Angleterre. Voilà.
Et quand vous étiez à la manœuvre,
ça éthiquement parlant le fait que ça
allait amener de la précarité dans les
rues, que ça allait amener de la
violence dans les rues, de la violence
dans les couples, des gens au chômage,
des gens qui clamsent, qui se suicident,
qui deviennent alcooliqu et j'en passe
des meilleurs. dans les salles de
marché, on se rend pas un peu la race ou
ou il y a quand même une petite éthique
en disant "Oh là quand même
non, moi j'ai eu la particularité de
voir ce que de comprendre les dégâts.
Mais et je vous dis pourquoi, pendant 10
ans, j'ai été trésorier de la fondation
de l'armée du salut de 95 à 2005.
C'était pour obsoudre votre âme ? Non,
c'était pour
remercier parce que moi j'ai eu une vie
et à l'époque, j'avais toujours une vie
intense et je renvoyais l'ascenseur.
Voilà, je me dis c'est ma façon de
renvoyer l'ascenseur, c'est de mettre
mes connaissances au service
des plus faibles, de ceux qui ont pas la
capacité que j'ai moi.
Et il y avait quelqu'un d'extraordinaire
qui dirigeait la fondation de l'armée du
salut qui s'appelait le le major du Chîn
à l'époque. La fondation l'armée du
salut, elle est laïque mais il y avait
des salutistes qui étaient protestants
qui étaient en uniforme et qui étaient
disons un peu la caution morale on va
dire. Bon elle est laïque parce qu'elle
reçoit des subventions de l'État et que
le gros de son budget c'est l'État et on
passait notre temps à ouvrir des centres
d'hébergement d'urgence à faire des
centres d'accueil et cetera. Et ça c'est
d'ailleurs c'est c'est c'était une
erreur.
Vous avez pris combien à attaquer la
banque d'Angleterre ?
J'en ai pas le je m'en souviens pas
vraiment. Non c'est pas
C'est combien votre bonus ?
Mais mais je vais je vois pourquoi vous
posez la question. Euh je vais répondre
au problème de l'ambiguité par rapport à
la misère qu'on peut créer. Et la misère
on la crée pas. La misère, c'est le
balancier qui va la créer. Plus vous
mentez, plus le retour de balancier est
fort. Quand on vous dit 120 % de la
dette, c'est pas un problème, le
balancier, il va il va il va redescendre
très fort. Vous allez le prendre très
fort. Il y aura énormément de pauvres à
cause de ça.
Si vous vous arrêtez avant et que vous
dites "OK, on a un problème de dette
publique, il faut une règle d'or dans la
Constitution, il faut pas qu'un
gouvernement puisse embarquer la France
au-delà d'une certaine d'un certain
montant, là vous commencez à freiner le
balancier et là vous faites le boulot
qui va permettre à des gens qui sont en
précarité de rester limité. vous savez
que ça va pas impacter tout le monde.
Alors que quand vous aurez une crise
monétaire importante, une crise
obligataire importante, qu'on pourra
plus lever de la dette parce qu'on est
incapable de la rembourser et que tout
le monde va le comprendre,
que la note française va se
et que la note française qui est déjà
plus triple A tout ça, ça va baisser.
Bon voilà, prenez le cas d'EDF,
ça va pas être privatisé ça.
Alors EDF, on vous dit voilà, il y a
maintenant il faut le plan Hercule
pour sauver EDF. Sauver EDF.
Attendez, mais moi quand j'étais
adolescent jusqu'à mon âge d'homme, EDF,
c'était l'État français, c'était un
paquebo économique, c'était un c'était
une entreprise qui avait le monopole,
qui fournissait l'électricité à tout le
monde, qui ne pouvait pas perdre
d'argent.
EDF, 60 milliards de dettes aujourd'hui
et les actifs, on se demande où ils
sont.
Alors on fait dire faut faire un plan
Hercule pour sauver EDF. Attendez la
capit quand il y a eu le premier
confinement même encore récemment à un
moment donné la capitalisation boursière
c'est-à-dire la valeur en bourse de DF
était à peu près équivalente à une fois
et demi le PR de Flamandville.
C'est tout.
Et on vous dit "Mais il y a pas de
problème.
Pourquoi vous inquiétez du plan Hercule
?
Attendez,
où ils sont ? Où est où est l'argent ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait avec British
Energy qu'on a acheté en 2010, qu'on a
surpayé ? Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait avec
tous ces EPR avec Incl Point ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ? Qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait qui est un véritable poison, un
véritable boulet pour la génération
d'après
qui n'a rien bénéficié mais de rien.
Autant moi je peux dire ma génération,
je suis né en 62, ma génération a
bénéficié d'une certaine croissance, a
bénéficier de la dette publique d'un
certain âge d'or. Mais mais les gens qui
sont nés à partir des années 90, on va
dire, mais ils ne font que payer.
Ils n'ont que de la dette à payer ces
gens-là. Allez, ils ont droit à des
petits boulots. Alors, on leur donne le
RSA, ils ont droit au RMI, les petits
boulots là, les voilà les boulots à 1000
balles.
Allez, vous avez fait 5 ans d'études, on
vous trouvera un stage à la BNP, hein.
Vous avez fait avant quelqu'un qui
faisait science pot, il avait un job.
Après,
science, aujourd'hui,
vous gagnez la misère.
Voilà. Donc
est-ce qu'il fallait est-ce qu'il faut à
un moment taper dans le dur, être
violent économiquement pour arrêter
peut-être ? Est-ce que c'est ça le rôle
? Ce qu'on appelait les gnomes de les
traders à un moment les appel
gnomesuriques. C'est une vieille
histoire. Ça remonta il y a longtemps
ça. Est-ce que c'est leur rôle de dire
"OK, on arrête maintenant ces bêtises là
et on dit la vérité à la population. Je
crois pas que ça soit le rôle mais ils
le font. Les crises économiques, c'est
quoi ? C'est ça. C'est le retour du
balancier.
Donc faisons juste en sorte que le
balancier arrête d'aller trop haut, ça
soit pas une fau qui vienne couper à
chaque fois le peu de croissance
économique qu'on est. C'est tout.
Donc vous avez pris combien avec la
Banque d'Angleterre ?
Je me honnêtement honnêtement je me
souviens plus. Je sais que ça a été une
bonne année. Je sais que quand moi j'ai
très bien vécu. Non mais je n'ai aucune
honte à ce niveau-là. J'ai très bien
vécu de mes années de trader. Je je
Combien vous preniez à l'époque ?
Oh, c'était en franc. Euh,
vous avz quoi comme voiture ?
J'ai une moto, j'ai pas mais c'est pas
grave. Mais mais je vivais bien. Non,
mais sans je vivais bien. J'ai eu une
première maison que j'ai payé rapidement
à 30 ans. Allez, je veux dire à 30 ans
j'avais déjà ma maison. Ma maison était
payée, je veux dire, alors que les gens
à 30 ans il ils s'endettent sur 20 ans.
Non, je vivais bien.
J'ai aucune
aucun
aucun regret, aucun
euh rien à cacher à ce niveau-là. Quand
je vous dis que je m'en souviens pas,
c'est c'est parce que on est passé à
l'euro que je sais plus ce que ça
représente par rapport à aujourd'hui,
mais je on vivait très bien. On vivait
très bien. Mais
incomptable, on pe pas dire ça.
Mais mais il y a pas de souci. Les
Golden Boy, les Golden Boy ont existé.
Les Golden Boy ont existé.
La cocaïne ?
Non, jamais jamais jamais jamais jamais.
S'il y a un truc que j'ai pas dans
lequel je suis pas tombé, que ça soit
sur le plan sportif ou le sur le plan du
travail, c'est bien dans toutes ces
histoires de stupéfiants ou de produits
euh stéréoïdes et cetera qui sont
monnaie courante aujourd'hui, vraiment
monnaie courante, euh qui sont une plaie
sur des théâtres de guerre. Et moi, je
j'ai toujours eu beaucoup de distance
par rapport aux gens qui travaillaient
en prenant ces produits-là parce que
vous vous dites le jour où il a plus
accès à ces produits-là, qu'est-ce qui
se passe ?
Mais vous envoyez beaucoup dans les dans
les forces militaires, j'aime pas le mot
force spéciale, mais on va on va
l'utiliser
pour passer les examens, pour passer les
épreuves et cetera de gens qui se
chargent comme des mules.
Bon mais c'est comme les combats de
boxe,
il y a pas de contrôle.
Vous c'était les femmes ?
Ah non, je suis je je n'ai été marié
qu'une fois. Je suis toujours marié.
Donc euh
Mais
au
courant que vous étiez sur l'état
d'opération.
Al non. Alors non. Alors non, ça c'est
non, c'est pas possible. En fait, ma
famille ne savait pratiquement rien et
ma femme, j'aimais pas que ma femme soit
au courant de choses pour pas
l'inquiéter euh et
parce que ça la regardait pas et qu'elle
aurait pas forcément compris. Et euh
c'est particulier quand vous avez pas le
vécu.
Moi quand on prononce le mot gangraine,
je sens l'odeur.
Voilà. Quand on quand je quand je vois
des yeux odeur, c'est quelle odeur ?
Je revois l'image, je revois les
blessures, je revois les yeux des gens.
C'était vert ou jaune ?
Voilà.
C'est
c'est sale.
Il avait des mouches.
Non, heureusement.
C'était où ?
C'était à Kirkook.
C'était quoi ? Du shrapnel ? C'était
quoi ?
Oui, voilà. Une blessure qui s'infecte.
Bien sûr à l'œil en plus. Voilà. Donc
ouais.
Voilà. Et ça c'est ça c'est dur. C'est
des moments durs que les gens peuvent
pas comprendre. On peut les expliquer
mais les gens peuvent pas comprendre.
Euh quand vous voyez une femme enceinte
agonisée
parce qu'elle peut pas accoucher parce
que
parce qu'elle peut pas accoucher
naturellement tout simplement parce
qu'elle peut pas accoucher naturellement
que vous la transportez dans votre
pickup
et qu'elle est morte au bout et que vous
savez et vous recommencez et que ça
marche pas et que de toute façon vous à
chaque fois qu'on vous en donne une ça
marche pas.
Vous dites
merde mais vous vous en souvenez vous
avez
c'est pas de votre faute he c'est pas de
votre fa cette femme à l'hôpital parce
que son père lui avait demandé
vous l'emmenez à l'hôpital parce qu'elle
peut pas accoucher naturellement et
parce qu'il y a pas d'infrastructure et
c'est trop long le trajet est trop long
et et c'est trop chaotique et il y a
rien, vous n'avez rien que vos mains
nues et que votre voiture et donc ça
marche pas
et quand vous êtes dans des pays comme
ça et quand vous ramenez le corps quand
ça arrive fréquemment que les gens
voient fréquemment des femmes enceintes
mourir parce qu'elles sont trop jeunes
pour avoir un enfant parce que l'enfant
il peut pas sortir parce qu'il sort par
le siège ou autre et que le seul moyen
c'est de les ventrer comme au Moyen-âge
et que on le fait pas.
Bah voilà, c'est dur. Et les gens après
vous leur expliquez que ah bah il faut
pas c'est leur vie que il faut pas
verser dans le terrorisme après, qu'il
faut pas se révolter.
Bon courage hein.
Donc après les salles de marché,
vous êtes parti faire de du
renseignement économique, c'est ça ?
Ouais.
On dit du renseignement économique ou de
l'intelligence du renseignement. Ouais.
Le renseignement
le renseignement
économique, c'est une c'est une vue de
l'esprit.
Euh si vous faites votre boulot que vous
avez tous les tenants et les
aboutissants,
c'est du renseignement tout court. Quand
vous faites une infiltration d'une
mafia, comment ça se fait une
infiltration de mafia ?
Il faut qu'il y ait un
un peu de naturel.
Ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que
vous avez votre histoire et vous devez
vous conforter à votre histoire être
dedans. Donc vous êtes
Suisse, banquier suisse, facilitateur
d'ouverture de compte suisse.
Ça se fait plus maintenant.
Vous allez si bien sûr que si vous allez
dans le nord de l'Irak et vous
rencontrez des gens en leur expliquant
avec un air un peu béné. Bah voilà, moi
je viens voir un peu où en est la
reconstruction. Euh
prendre l'accent ou pas ?
Non. J'ai des investisseurs en Suisse
qui seraient susceptible.
Non non, il faut pas aller sur quelque
chose qui vous force à faire une faute.
Vous avez fait quoi vous ? Moi, j'avais
euh j'avais un document qui était un
document suisse
qui n'était pas contrefait,
un passeport,
non,
mais euh et donc qui était un vrai
document suisse. Euh donc mon mon
discours tenait la route. Est-ce que je
pouvais faciliter l'ouverture d'un
compte en Suisse ? La réponse est oui.
Euh est-ce que j'avais des investisseurs
suisses qui voulaient investir sur
l'Irak ? Bon, ça c'est beaucoup plus
aléatoire, je dirais non, mais du moment
que les gens peuvent le croire et ben il
vous entourent et et surtout vous prenez
pas un air agressif. Vous êtes là parce
que vous êtes dans la finance suisse et
cetera et donc ah bah pourquoi les gens
se méfieraient ? Vous vous êtes seul,
vous êtes voilà bon vous venez faire un
tour, vous venez voir ce qui se passe,
vous avez le courage de venir voir ce
qui se passe, trouver des partenaires
pour la reconstruction et puis vous
attirez comme un aimant toute le
racaille. Et comme un aimant.
Vous étiez venus avec un peu de
chocolat, une cloche ?
Même pas. Même pas. Et la racaille, en
fait, elle est attachante.
Vous tombez sur des gens. Le patron, un
des patrons de la mafia, il m'avait il
m'avait raconté des histoires. Il
m'avait dit, il avait été en contact à
l'époque de Sadame avec Hou et Kousai
Husen, les fills de Sadame.
C'est ceux qui gazaient chimiquement
tout le monde là.
Voilà. Voilà, voilà. et et euh il
m'avait dit "Mais tu vois euh moi j'ai
eu telle partie du marché de contrebande
de la cigarette et je et j'ai bien baisé
Hudaï. On avait été à Chypre et à un
moment je lui ai laissé tel marché, je
savais que ce marché-là était moins bon
et en échange, il m'avait donné telle
telle autre zone géographique et je
savais que c'était bien meilleur. Et
c'est pas parce que j'avais eu ces
renseignements là que je j'ai accepté le
marché et lui il avait ou il y avait le
sentiment d'avoir passé un bon marché et
cetera et c'est comme ça que je l'ai
baisé et cetera. Je vous dis ça avec en
plus ils avaient un langage out trancié.
Euh on parle de quelqu'un qui savait à
peine à peine lire et écrire mais qui
savait remarquablement compter ça. Il
savait parfaitement ce que c'était une
marge. Un logisticien hors paire hors
paire.
Et donc un personnage un peu attachant
euh avec les limites que bon il avait un
droit de vie ou de mort sur ses hommes
euh qui vivait entouré de garde du
corps, que sa famille était une bande de
crétins congénitaux mais comme on
nimagine pas et qu'ils étaient capables
du pire.
C'est quoi l'hyne national suisse
où il a changé récemment ? Je saurais
pas vous le dire. Je saurais pas vous le
dire. Je vous en 2 minutes, hein.
Mais vous savez le président suisse, il
change tous les ans. Donc même les
Suisses de temps en temps, ils savent
plus trop où ils en sont.
Ils connaissent leur hymne. Vous
inquiétez pas.
Non
non, les Suisses en fait, ils font leur
militaire en Suisse, donc ils ont leur
rythme et cetera. Mais mais euh ça
n'empêche que vous avez 70 % de la
population de Genève qui est d'origine
émigrée. Vous avez du suisse pur, il y
en a peu et euh et ça va très bien.
Ça veut dire quoi Suisse ?
Et vous savez euh dans dans des pays
comme l'Irak, vous tombez sur des gens
qui sont arabophones mais qui sont
analphabètes dans notre
dans notre alphabet à nous qui ne lisent
pas notre alphabet.
Donc vous leur montrez un document avec
un drapeau, bah c'est le drapeau qui
compte à l'aéroport. Vous êtes pas
monsieur échanger Marc, vous êtes
monsieur Marc.
Et ça dans beaucoup de pays d'Afrique
aussi.
Ça change tout. C'est pas du tout la
même perception que ce qu'on a en
Europe.
Donc allez chercher un monsieur Marc.
OK, bonne chance.
Donc et vous changez d'endroit tous les
de tr jours.
Il faut éviter d'avoir d'être au même
endroit plus de de tr jours. C'est quand
même bon.
Mais voilà.
Après, ça se passe bien pour certains et
mal pour d'autres he tout le monde s'en
est pas sorti.
Comme quoi vous en avez perdu un peu ?
Malheureusement euh
celui qui était le plus proche de moi,
on travaillait vraiment en binô
resté beaucoup trop longtemps
et on a perdu la raison. Donc pour lui,
ça a été très dur. il est pas rentré
chez lui. Bon, c'est ça, c'est ça perdu
la raison. C'est qu'il a trouvé
il a perdu la raison. Il a perdu la
raison.
Voilà, il a sombré
quand il est rentré chez lui aux
États-Unis. Ça s'est très mal terminé.
Euh, il s'est retrouvé à la rue. Voilà.
Et ouais, le prix à payer, c'est pas le
prix au jourg J, c'est le prix, il est
longtemps après. Longtemps après, vous
avez encore des gars qui suicident.
B voilà.
que ça soit d'ailleurs aux États-Unis ou
en Angleterre, même s'il y a un suivi,
contrairement à ce qu'on pense, il y a
un suivi qui se fait, le retour est
extrêmement violent. Euh
vous vous avez toutes sortes de phobies
y compris le fait d'être aller
simplement faire vos courses dans un
grand magasin
et simplement acheter vos boîtes de
conserve et tout ça. Vos courses de tout
quotidienne dans un grand magasin. C'est
un peu angoissant par moment parce que
vous avez tout d'un coup aucune
sécurité, beaucoup de monde autour de
vous et hop là vous avez les vieux
réflexes qui reviennent. Euh vous partez
de Kirkook, euh vous déchargez votre
armement, votre gilet par balle et tout
ça pour prendre l'avion. vous retrouvez
quelques heures après, quelques heures,
même pas quelques jours dans un aéroport
européen.
Le choc est rude. Le choc est tellement
rude que un moment pour nous, on était
assez repéré, on rentrait par
l'Allemagne, les douiniers allemands
avaient été formés euh quand il nous
demandaient nos papiers, quand il nous
quand nous voyait arriver euh soit de
Bagdad, soit d'Arbil. Euh
opérit comment à la poussière, à la
fatigué
alors euh déjà au ticket de de le billet
d'avion. Euh l'Autriche, c'est pareil
aussi, on passait par l'Autriche,
passé par la Croatie, ça passe mieux.
Et et euh il y avait euh il se méfiait
dans ce sens que il nous parlait
doucement euh et il faisait attention.
Moi, je me souviens à un moment euh il
me demande de retirer mes chaussures et
puis j'avais un sparadra sur ma
chaussure avec mon groupe sanguin euh et
j'avais oublié de retirer le sparadra.
Et donc le gars, il prend ma chaussure,
il voit le groupe sang
et il me sourit. Il me dit "On peut le
retirer ?"
Ouais. Voilà. Et donc j'ai retiré.
Voilà. Et
mais voilà, il ils sont formés
aujourd'hui à ce genre de chos vous êtes
jamais euh au retour parce que moi quand
je vous entends parler,
je vais pas dire que j'ai des potes
mercenaires, mais des histoires comme
ça, j'en ai déjà entendu. Et
vous êtes jamais débriefié,
débriefé par les services. Les services
vous regardent pas de travers. Qu'est-ce
qui se passe ?
qui vous que les gens vous regardent de
travers,
par jour, c'est pas cher hein.
Que que vous que les gens vous regardent
de travers, c'est pas un problème. Ils
ont qu'à faire le boulot.
Euh évidemment, vous êtes débriefé.
Évidemment, vous espérez arriver à faire
votre job. Vous voulez vous voulez que
ça ça se passe bien.
Vous voulez progresser, vous avez à cœur
de faire ça.
Vous avez déjà tué
indirectement ?
J'ai pas pris mon arme pour vous tirer
dessus comme je le ferai aujourd'hui là.
Comment vous faites pour passer vos
armes ?
Ah bah les armes, ça c'est pas un
problème. Déjà vous avez des marchés
d'armes un peu partout sur toutes les
zones de guerre. Donc faut bien se
rendre compte d'une chose.
Votre arme préféré c'est quoi ?
Le Glock. les la gamme des Glocks, moi
j'aiquel
le Glock 21, le Glock 19 euh même si les
Glocks plus compacts sont plus récent
mais
Ouais,
le 17 c'est ça ?
Non, le Glock 21, j'aime bien aussi.
Mais mais pourquoi le Glock ? Bah parce
que vous avez un système de queue de
détente qui est bien particulier, avec
lequel vous êtes en confort. En fait, il
faut surtout pas avoir peur de votre
arme. Il faut être à l'aise avec. Vous
avez pas toujours le temps de vous
entraîner beaucoup, donc il faut être à
l'aise avec ce que vous avez. Voilà. Et
et moi personnellement euh
j'ai bien aimé
les les la calache, les vieilles les
vieilles calaches, je les trouve euh
hyper solides, hyper fiable. Euh et le
fait de pouvoir défoncer un mur avec la
crosse, un mur en brique et que la
crosse bouge pas, je trouve ça
confortable. Voilà.
C'est pas de la chinoise.
Ouais. et et euh
et on comprend pourquoi c'est utilisé
partout. Voilà. Bon,
alors que dans un FAMAS qui existe plus
maintenant, vous aviez plus d'une
vingtaine de pièces. Bon, euh
en plus ça rouille, hein.
Oh, ça c'est
Vous avez vu des gens sous Captagon ?
Euh oui, sous alors sous différents
trucs. Alors pas que sous Captagon qui
vous avez différentes pilules euh qui
sont arrivés euh à peu près à partir de
2008 euh sur la zone irakienne euh et
qui sont aussi liés à l'évolution de la
guerre en Afghanistan. En Afghanistan,
c'est intéressant de le noter, on a en
Afghanistan euh à un moment, on s'est
dit euh on va amener l'eau potable, on
va amener l'eau d'irrigation dans
certaines cultures, à certains endroits,
on va reconstruire des barrages et
cetera et on l'a fait et on s'est pas
rendu compte que avec cette eau
d'irrigation, ce qui allait pousser,
c'était de l'opium, c'était du pavau.
Et la production d'opium est passée à je
crois 8000 tonnes. Enfin, ça atteint des
sommets et cetera. Alors, il faut dire
aux gens une chose, c'est que ça se
transporte pas à doane.
Il faut qu'il y ait des avions
qui prennent cet opium là, qui le
chargent et qui l'emporte. Et ça part en
Inde, ça part en Turquie notamment.
Et parce que ces gens-là ont des
licences pour travailler
l'opium et pour en faire différents
produits pharmaceutiques, il travaillent
aussi la drogue. Et voilà, c'est comme
ça qu'on se retrouve dans tous nos
petits villages avec des dérivés d'opium
qui viennent d'Afghanistan.
Mais c'est aussi la période où le crime
organisé débarque avec la reconstruction
et le crime organisé son effet de levier
c'est la drogue. Et la drogue qui
existait quasiment pas à l'époque de sa
dame devient omniprésente sous forme de
pilule. Donc c'est pas c'est pas que du
Captagon, c'est des enfits. Euh moi je
suis pas spécialiste de ça, mais c'est
euh c'est des produits qui contiennent
des euh des des produits qui vont vous
euh sentir euh qui vont vous couper la
faim, qui qui vont vous apporter un
certain bien-être. Euh et donc tout ça
va arriver par sachet entier euh en Irak
et vous verrez après des gens qui
comprennent pas pourquoi ils sont accros
à ces produits-là et qui vont faire la
queue aux hôpitaux en essayant de
comprendre qu'est-ce qui leur arrive.
Ces mêmes produits là, je les ai vu
débarquer en Afrique de l'Ouest
à partir de 2014 environ.
C'est venu, les pilules sont venues du
Nigéria et ça a commencé à remonter vers
le Niger, Mali et cetera et ça et c'est
une catastrophe. On parle de pilules
donc qui vont vous donner un certain
bien-être
et euh ça se prend par vous en prenez
par poignet. Dans certains cas, les
chauffeurs prennent ça parce qu' c'est
des gens qui ont une vie extrêmement
dure. Euh et euh euh bah voilà, c'est
comme ça que des pays qui avant ne
faisaient que d'être des pays de transit
pour la drogue, notamment pour la
cocaïne, deviennent des pays
consommateurs mais consommateurs de
drogues de pauvre.
Mettons le cannabis de côté. Le
cannabis, il a des effets très
particuliers pour la médecine et cetera.
Ça peut être utilisé pour les diarrées.
Euh ça c'est un produit pour moi qui est
plus médical qu'autre chose, mais euh la
cocaïne c'était une drogue qui était pas
consommée et qui l'est pas d'ailleurs en
Afrique de l'Ouest. Mais ces pays-là
servent de pays de transit
vers l'Europe. Alors que maintenant euh
non seulement ils font toujours ça, mais
en plus ils consomment des pilules.
Et les pilules, je les ai vu débarquer.
C'était au départ assez peu réservé aux
zones où il y avait de la population
assez dense, hein, les les grandes
villes. Euh et maintenant dans chaque
village, vous avez la petite
pharmacopée, vous retrouvez des petites
pilules bleues et des machins et des
trucs.
Qu'est-ce que vous savez dire en arabe ?
Peu de choses euh
vraiment les Non non vraiment peu de
choses.
Comment on dit mine antipersonnel ?
Non IOD enfin les Iodon en arabe non
même pas.
Non, même pas. Ça n'a pas d'intérêt.
S'il y a une chose qu'il faut pas
vouloir faire, c'est parler la langue
de des gens avec lesquels vous allez que
vous risquez d'infiltrer avec les gens
vous que ça soit laa l'arabe, le kurde,
vous n'arriverez jamais
en temps donné à parler suffisamment
bien toutes les langues dans lesquelles
le nand pour le Norquivou.
Vous allez bredouiller quelques mots.
Oui. Par politesse.
Par politesse,
c'est tout. Soyez poli avec moi en
arabe.
Euh
bah ne serait-ce que répondre salam
alkoum quand vous dites salam alkoum.
Enfin la base savoir queil y a cinq
prières par jour. À quelle heure on fait
la prière, à quelle heure on fait la
prière, les choses comme ça. Bon voilà.
Mais ça c'est ça n'a rien à voir avec la
langue elle-même. Il y a quelques
euh
allez
quelques les mots comme ismi enfin
quelques mots qui peuvent être utilisés
pour se faire comprendre de temps en
temps mais vous avez tellement à
apprendre que c'est pas possible. Soit
vous avez une mission militaire à longue
durée et vous allez vous mettre à vous
allez apprendre avec Roseta Stone qui
est utilisé par toutes les agences pour
apprendre les langues. Soit vous avez
des missions précises et vous changez de
zone. Bon mais en ce qui concerne les
dialectes africains, comment voulez-vous
apprendre ? Amzungu ? Vous savez ce que
c'estu ?
Oui bien sûr.
C'est quoi ?
C'est le blanc qui vient donner des
leçons. Voilà.
Mais ça Mozungu, ils connaissent pas
l'expression au Niger,
il y a autre chose mais c'est la zone à
Oousa et quand vous allez au Niger mais
mais vous n'avez pas que laa zone àousa,
elle est bien déterminée. Après vous
avez la partie de Niamé qui ne parle pas
la housa, vous avez le Canourri, vous
avez vous avez tellement de vous avez le
le le dialecte que parlent les Toareg,
le Tamek.
Comment voulez-vous ? Vous ne donnerez
jamais le change. À moins de passer 20
ans avec des toit règles, là vous
finirez par parler Tamek. Mais sinon,
c'est pas la peine.
Question d'internet. Qu'est-ce qui vous
arrive ? Alors, qu'est-ce qui vous
arriverait si vous mettiez un pied en
Chine ?
Je pense que
je reprendrai l'avion assez rapidement.
Les pieds devant ? Non, pas forcément,
mais je pense que ça voilà, on me dirait
gentiment la porter là.
Question d'internet. Que pensent-il du
service action de la DGSE ?
Il manque de moyens.
Euh je vais vous donner un exemple pour
pour illustrer mon propos.
Quand vous faites l'opération Géronymo
qui permet de liquider Ben Laden,
vous la faites avec des hélicoptères qui
sont tous des prototypes.
Vous la faites avec des hommes qui vont
s'entraîner avec la reconstitution
complète du site
qui vont tirer jusqu'à 1000 munitions
par homme et par jour pendant toute la
durée de l'entraînement.
et vous la faites avec des moyens
d'écoute, d'assistance démesuré, un coup
d'opération qui est quasiment sans
limite. Quand l'opération Jéronymo
commence,
il y a personne qui lève la main pour
dire "Ah bah combien ça va coûter ?"
On l'a fait.
Quand vous avez des opérations du
service action,
c'est pas des prototypes,
c'est pas le même entraînement,
c'est pas les mêmes moyens. On appelle
on appelle des alliés pour pour aider.
Oui, on appelle les alliés pour aider.
Qu'est-ce que vous en savez ?
Parce que il y a des débriefings, parce
que ça a eu lieu, parce que ça a été
dans certains cas des échecs et qu'on
cherche à les analyser.
L'affaire
en Somalie a été un échec. Il fallait
comprendre pourquoi par la Somalie
l'aigle noir là quand le faucon noir.
Non. Alors, ça a été non l'affaire
française en Somalie
de Denis Alex, le sauvetage de Denis
Alex qui était mourant au moment où le
sauvetage a eu lieu. Euh et euh
une des erreurs, mais bon, on peut
toujours après, c'est facile de dire ça,
ça a été de partir de beaucoup trop
loin,
de marcher longtemps avant d'arriver sur
le site de l'intervention.
d'avoir mal anticipé la réponse armée
qu'il pouvait y avoir.
Tout ça manquement de renseignement
hein, c'est difficile.
Donc je blâme personne. Le résultat des
courses, c'est que la préparation pour
cette opération là
n'est pas du même de la même qualité
qu'une opération Jéronymo.
Je vous ferai remarquer au passage que
le médecin
qui a été chargé de faire la vaccination
et qui a vérifié que Ben Laden était
bien dans le le médecin, lui il est
toujours en prison. Il a jamais été
libéré, il est toujours en prison au
Pakistan. Donc il y a un homme qui s'est
sacrifié pour que cette opération là
puisse se faire.
Du pognon hein.
Non non le médecin, il est en prison. Il
savait qu'il allait où ? Le médecin
pakistanais qui a donné l'information
comme quoi Ben Laden était bien à cet
endroit-là,
il savait qu'il se sacrifiait.
Qui vous paye en ce moment ?
En ce moment, j'ai je travaille sur une
grosse opération qui est donc celle du
financement de Daesh proau. Donc je suis
payé par personne. Euh
une rémunération ? Non, j'ai plus besoin
de travailler pour de l'argent. Je
C'està-dire
c'est-à-dire que je peux vivre avec
l'épargne que j'ai. Euh j'ai 58 ans,
donc la retraite est là aussi.
Vous pz combien ?
Je pèse combien ?
Pas assez pour être soumis à comment à
l'impôt sur la fortune immobilière.
Et puis j'ai plus de famille à charge.
Donc voilà.
Je peux vivre sur mon épargne, il y a
pas de problème. Après après je
j'ai des rémunérations parce que on
m'apporte des des des contrats, il y a
toujours des choses à faire et cetera et
que ça me fait vivre. Mais bon,
en enquêtant un peu sur vous, euh il y a
des bris de couloir qui me sont venus
aux oreilles.
Ouais.
En me disant "Ce mec euh il enquête sur
les phénomènes de corruption pour se
faire payer par les Américains."
Pas du tout.
Alors, on peut se faire payer par les
Américains en enquêtant sur les
phénomènes de corruption, mais le la
mécanique est est assez particulière.
Euh vous devez d'abord
euh négocier soit avec moi j'ai
travaillé pour ICE par exemple euh dire
Ice c'est immigration custom
enforcement.
Perfect
accent.
Ouais, merci. Euh donc ils sont basés à
Miami.
Vous avez été fermé aux États-Unis ?
Non du tout.
Le contre terro qui est-ce qui vous l'a
appris ?
Alors j'ai fait Saintandrou des études à
Saint-Androu. Euh et la personne qui m'a
ouvert les portes euh est un général euh
qui a commandé les SAS euh et ça je lui
en suis reconnaissant euh parce que ça
permet d'avoir des contacts dans ce
milieu-là, de rencontrer des gens. Bon,
j'en avais rencontré aussi sur le
terrain, mais de de gens de de très haut
niveau. Les les on va dire que dans le
top 5 du contreerrorisme international,
il y a pas de français. Et donc
euh c'est intéressant d'avoir des
d'avoir voilà de partager les
connaissances avec ces gens-là parce que
c'est des puits de sciences et
malheureusement c'est des gens qui
commencent à être assez âgés. Euh et le
jour où ces gens vont disparaître, on va
perdre un savoir-faire qui est euh qui
est qui est vraiment préjudicable. C'est
vraiment préjudiciable.
Donc pour en revenir à à comment est-ce
qu'on peut vivre en en vendant euh des
opérations de corruption aux États-Unis,
euh
c'est difficile euh
mais c'est possible parce que le
département of de justice il rémunère
des informateurs. C'est pas comme la
France.
qui elle ne fait tout pour ne pas qu'
ait d'informateur.
On sait jamais s'il y en a trop d'un
coup hein.
Voilà, surtout pas d'informateur.
Les États-Unis, c'est le contraire.
Est-ce qu'on peut vivre comme ça ? Non,
mais ça peut motiver pour faire des
opérations et en tout cas ça peut
permettre de de faire comprendre à la
famille qu'il faut aller au bout. Moi,
ça m'est arrivé en travaillant pour ICE
euh de travailler avec un un pseudonyme
et euh
il y avait une la difficulté, maintenant
je peux en parler, vous on est vous
aviez une famille iraakienne importante
cheit euh qui avait à bouger 500
millions de dollars en billet. Donc ça
ça représente une masse en camion qu'il
faut trimballer. Euh c'est 500 millions,
un petit JF. Voilà, ces 500 millions
quand moi j'étais dans la boucle à un
moment devait partir par Bassra,
aller jusqu'à aller et se retrouver en
Suisse pour faire cours. Bon euh et donc
le but du jeu avec Ice, c'était de
suivre ce cache, d'aller sur le bateau
et c'est là où eux ils ont des moyens
phénoménaux. C'est il m' ils m'ont dit à
un moment t'inquiète pas monte sur le
bateau avec le cache. Tu suis ton
infiltration, tu continues, tu montes
sur le bateau avec ton cache. Euh on va
intercepter le bateau et ça se passera
bien. Je dis mais une fois que le bateau
il est dans la
en pleine mer, comment on fait quoi ?
Elle me dit mais on a un sous-marin.
Effectivement on joue pas avec les mêmes
moyens.
Euh et donc
ils avaient un sous-marin
d'intervention. il y aurait eu ils
auraient raisonné le bateau euh et
fait une intervention militaire comme
ça. Bon
donc en tout cas ils avaient le soutien
de la marine et c'est comme ça que j'ai
compris aussi que leurs agences depuis
le 11 septembre travaillaient en rateau
et parfaitement en concertation ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant
et ça c'est un gros plus.
Et au bout d'un moment donc on continue
et
l'objectif change. L'argent au lieu
d'aller vers la Suisse va vers le Liban
et là il y a pas bon. Et là il est pas
question d'aller suivre l'argent. Et en
fait, cet argent-là a été utilisé et
blanchi au Liban en achetant cash des
appartements notamment aux chrétiens
libanais
en leur disant "Bah voilà, on vous
propose 120 % de la valeur de votre
appartement, c'est payé en cash. Vous
prenez ou pas ?"
Beaucoup ont pris.
C'est comme ça qu'une partie de l'argent
a été blanchi. Mais là, je pouvais rien
faire. Mais au moins, j'ai su.
C'est quoi votre handicap au golf ?
Je joue pas.
Voilà. Désolé
si vous êtes passé à Saint-Androuse.
Non, vous êtes même pas 7. SaintAndro
est réputé pour son golf. Mais moi non,
je pas je joue pas au golf, j'ai chose à
faire.
Et comment comment vous imaginez
l'avenir ? Question d'internet.
Comment imagine-tils l'avenir ?
Moi, je voudrais vraiment, s'il y a un
combat qui me tient à cœur, c'est le
combat sur le financement de Daesh.
Et
c'est pour toper ce qu'on a mangé. C'est
pour remonter jusqu'
Ouais. Ouais. pour dire à ces gens-là,
envoyer un bon message et leur dire
voilà vous aurez la punition
vous et je veux qu'il la sente venir.
Voilà,
on est beaucoup comme ça non ?
Ouais. Et ça ça me ferait plaisir voilà
qu'il la sente venir et
sentir la peur dans le dans sur le
visage de son ennemi. Ça c'est du
bonheur quand même, on peut le dire.
C'est jouissif.
Je suis désolé mais c'est jouissif et ça
savoir que ça arrive, savoir que les
procureurs italiens montrent le dossier
ça qui sentent que la prison c'est une
hypothèse.
Il vont ramasser le savon.
Voilà voilà voilà. Et qui vont payer
pour tout ce qui a été fait.
Vous avez déjà subi un interrogatoire ?
Oui. Un peu musclé.
Un peu musclé. Vous étiez à genou sur
des peu musclé. c'est que
la personne était euh menaçante euh
demander à ses gardes du corps de venir
dans la pièce
et ça aurait pu mal se terminer. Ouais.
Ouais.
Pour eux ou pour vous ?
Pour eux. Pour eux parce que j'avais un
backup et que si je donnais pas un
signal à un moment donné ou si ça se
passait resterit trop longtemps, il y
aurait une intervention.
C'est là où il faut avoir confiance.
Voilà. Donc c'est comme ça.
Est-ce que la DG Est-ce que la DGSE vous
a appris
résister à la torture ?
Personne ne vous apprend à résister à la
torture. Vous la subissez. Ça peut faire
dans certains cas partie de votre
entraînement, dans certains cas dans
certaines agences, pas ma connaissance à
la DGSE, mais je suis pas
capable de vous dire s'il y a pas eu des
exceptions à un moment ou un autre.
Le fait est c'est que c'est pas la même
formation que les agents israéliens qui
eux malheureusement doivent subir ça euh
de les agents israéliens doivent subir
ça
parce que ça fait partie de leur
formation et que de dans le camp adverse
aussi on les entraîne à subir la même
chose.
Le esbola est un corps d'élite
vraiment
euh qui a sa partie renseignement, sa
partie d'effort spécial, une branche
militaire, une branche d'ingénieur, un
corps d'élite. C'est plus dur de rentrer
au Esbola
qu'à la Légion. À la Légion, vous avez
allez, on va dire
20 % de chance de rentrer. Le SBOLa,
vous êtes à 10 %. Ils sont extrêmement
méfiants
et ils vous apprennent
à des techniques d'interrogatoire
musclé. Il vous apprennent à résister à
ça. Des deux côtés, vous avez ça. Des
deux côtés, vous avez la détermination
absolue.
En France, vous avez moins besoin parce
que l'époque est pas là. En France, vous
avez eu des gens qui ont une
détermination absolue au moment de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale, mais après, il
y a eu moins de besoins. Il y a donc il
y a eu moins d'enseignement, ça a
évolué, c'est pas du tout la même chose.
La Libye, ça va se terminer comment ?
ça va se terminer euh par une fragilité
permanente. On a vraisemblablement on
aura euh une possibilité de de réduire
la violence
mais il y aura une instabilité
permanente. Ça sera très difficile de
retrouver
une stabilité comme à l'époque de
Kaddafi. Est-ce que Kaddafi est un but
en soi ? Est-ce que c'était
c'est ce qu'il faudrait atteindre ? Non.
Euh mais euh est-ce qu'on peut concevoir
que euh Saïf et l'Islam euh reviennent
au pouvoir ? Euh,
ça c'est pas possible. La France
laissera pas faire.
La France a pas dire son mot à ce
niveau-là. Euh et euh ça fait partie des
hypothèses sur lesquelles plusieurs pays
travaillent et se mettent d'accord. Euh
si ça peut permettre de pacifier cette
zone là, bah ma fois c'est un moindre
mal. C'est des pays qui n'ont pas
l'habitude euh de la démocratie comme
nous on la conçoit.
C'est des pays tout ce qu'ils veulent la
stabilité. Alors c'est c'est facile de
dire ça. Ils veulent la stabilité et la
liberté.
Voilà. Et la stabilité. Donc des
élections comme nous on en a, c'est pas
leur truc parce qu'ils ont pas
d'opposition, parce qu'ils ont pas de
culture d'opposition puisque c'est des
pays qui n'ont connu qu'une dictature et
on on fait en sorte qu'il y ait pas
d'opposition. Donc il peut pas y avoir
de changement démocratique comme pour
nous. Euh mais voilà euh si un jour on
les laisse vivre, je pense qu'ils
vivront mieux en Libye le jour où il y
aura plus de pétrole.
Là on va leur [__] la paix d'habitude
hein.
Voilà.
Question internet. Quit de l'espionnage
sur notre sol par les grandes
puissances. On parle pas de surveillance
télécom mais d'infiltration en
présentiel.
Ouais.
Il y a qui qui se bal il y a des gens
remarquables pour ça. Les Russes sont
remarquables. Les Russes sont
remarquables.
Des exemples.
J'ai rencontrer une fois un ancien
colonel du KGB qui était d'origine
arménienne
et
donc il était assez âgé. Il se cachait
pas d'avoir été du KGB.
Non, je vous donnerai pas le nom. Mais
quelle année ?
Oh, c'était dans
20112 quelque chose.
Rencontré où ? Euh je l'ai rencontré en
Suisse
et
cet homme-là parlait français
remarquablement.
Il était parfaitement capable de se
faire passer pour un français de souche
avec aucun accent notoire d'aucun on ne
pouvait pas déterminer qu'il n'était pas
français.
Et je lui ai dit "Mais c'est quand même
extraordinaire la façon dont vous parlez
français, le
le vocabulaire, la précision des mots.
Euh mais comment vous arrivez ? Vous
avez vécu en France ? Mais j'ai pas vécu
en France." Il me dit "Marc, c'est
l'école du KGB."
Et là, chapeau
chapeau bas. Et donc oui, des infiltrés
russes, il y en a. Il y en a toujours,
il y en a toujours eu. Bon, le premier
doit, ça doit être dans les années 1920
quelque chose comme ça de mémoire.
Euh et puis il y en a toujours eu. Vous
avez aussi une partie de l'armée
française, des officiers françaises qui
est prusse, naturellement prusse
parce qu'ils estime que Poutine c'est
l'homme fort, que c'est le contrepouvoir
par rapport aux États-Unis qui a déçu
et que en fait bah faire une alliance
avec la Russie, c'est la Russie
chrétienne, c'est la Russie qui gagne,
c'est la Russie de Poutine et il voi cet
aspect-là et ils se disent "Bah ça c'est
pas gênant euh
gênant d'avoir des des forces qui ne
sont pas loyales à notre président.
C'est gênant euh d'avoir des forces qui
considèrent que euh le ceux qui les
dirigent euh ne sont pas vraiment
légitimes.
Voilà, qu'ils ont pas la légitimité
euh de terrain. Je pense que quelqu'un
par moi je j'admire beaucoup Churchill.
Je pense que quelqu'un comme Churchill
qui avait connu la guerre dans sa
jeunesse
qui savait ce que c'était que le sang et
les larmes pouvait en parler et qui a pu
mener son peuple là où il l'a mené.
Il l'a mené avec justesse
parce que il savait convaincre et que
les gens lui donnaient
lui donnaient crédit. Euh quand
quelqu'un comme Macron dit "On ne
parlera jamais au djihadistes", en
parlant de la ceux qui sont dans la zone
barcane, euh je me dis ça c'est
complètement idiot. Euh on parle
toujours à son ennemi, sinon on peut pas
faire la paix. Pour faire la guerre,
comme pour faire la paix, il faut être
deux. Euh et quand il parle de la guerre
et de Barkane et du Sahel, il ne sait
pas de quoi il parle. Penser penser
en France au moment où Hollande est élu
aussi qui était euh aux affaires
étrangères Jean-Marcot
le leur le dormeur du quai.
Voilà, on a à un même moment on a Héros
Leillant et au-dessus Hollande. Et c'est
à ce moment-là qu'on déclenche
l'opération Serval. OK. Serval c'est 6
mois.
Derrière, on pas pour 7 ans de barcane.
Une opération militaire, il faut un
budget,
un motif précis,
un objectif précis
et un horizon de temps.
Si vous avez ça là, au moins vos
troupes, elles savent ce qu'elles
doivent faire et comment elles vont
faire avec le budget. Là, on est parti
sur le budget,
le ciel est la limite.
L'objectif
bombarder 50 gaz de temps en temps avec
des Mirages 2000 quand la presse
commence à montrer les dents
parce que l'objectif maintenant on sait
plus trop, c'est pas l'immigration,
c'est pas réduire l'immigration.
Et l'horizon de temps, alors l'horizon
de temps c'est quoi ?
Vous avez le général coin qui vous dit
encore 10 ans
encore ? Mais pourquoi 10 ans ? Pourquoi
pas 8 20 encore ? L'horizon de temps sa
pas
comment voulez-vous que ça marche et
c'est quand même des gens qui ont vu que
l'Afghanistan était un échec non
seulement pour nous mais pour les Russes
avant
qui ont vu que l'Irak était un échec et
qui nous disent "Attendez, nous on fait
Barcan là et ça peut durer autant de
temps qu'on veut.
Revenons, revenons à la présentielle des
des Russes sur notre territoire.
Ouais.
D'autres détails ?
Il y a pas que les Russes, vous avez
aussi les Israéliens.
Vous avez vous avez les Iraniens dans
une moindre mesure. Euh mais beaucoup de
puissances étrangères parce que c'est
facile Américains, les Américains
mais des Américains aussi. Mais c'est
facile la France c'est facile d'
Pourquoi ? C'est un gruillère, c'est une
mode de beurre.
Oui, c'est un gruère. Mais comment
voulez-vous ? Mais comment voulez-vous
que la DGSI avec le peu de moyens qu'il
y a là, puisse faire quelque chose ?
Mais comment voulez-vous ? La DGSI,
c'est l'ancienne DCI, hein. On est c'est
Squar Cini qui nous met ça en route
déjà. Bon, il nous met ça à Levalois
Perz chez son ami Balcani.
Vous voyez un peu le contexte dans
lequel on et et il y a pas de
définition. On lui dit
sûr qu'il savent avec qui se pose sur le
bout de
on lui dit on fait un FBI à la française
mais allez voir à Quantico le FBI.
Le FBI c'est 15000 agents qui ont une
formation béton en tron commun.
La DGSI la DGSI c'est laissé un bout de
chandelle ici un bout de ficelle. Allez
tiens et un petit bout ici. Alors on va
faire un peu de cyber là hein. Et puis
un c'est quoi ? de même que dans le dans
le dans le domaine de la criminalité
financière,
vous avez la brigade financière, vous
avez l'ossif, c'est ceux qui font la
corruption, vous avez la brigade de
répression de la délinquence financière,
br délinquence économique, vous avez
ceux qui font la grande délinquence
économique,
on les multip, vous avez traque faim, on
les multiplie. On sait pas en faire un
qui soit efficace,
un qui soit efficace.
Vous avez à la brigade financière, vous
avez aujourd'hui 10 fois moins de moyens
qu'il y a 20 ans. À l'époque où on a
fait le l'appel de Genève avec les juges
d'instruction, il y avait plus de moyens
qu'aujourd'hui à la brigade financière.
Comment vous connaissez la DGSI, son
fonctionnement ?
Bah, ça fait partie des agences sur
lequel on doit s'informer, sur qu'on
voit travailler aussi. Ils ont travaillé
sur moi, je leur en veux pas.
Comment ? Comment vous savez ?
Mais parce que quand vous sortez
l'affaire OSRA qui touche le Premier
ministre, bah immanquablement ils ont
appelé ma banque. Ils ont essayé de me
chercher des pou. Je leur en veux pas,
ils font leur boulot. C'est leur boulot.
Pourquoi ils ont essayé de chercher des
pou ?
Pour voir qui payait quoi. Est-ce que
j'étais pas un agent étranger ? Est-ce
que je travaillais pas pour la
corruption des Américains et cetera ?
Non. Voilà, l'affaire au serrage l'
sortie. Euh, je suis content qu'Algor se
soit pas présenté à la présidentielle.
Pourqu Vous savez qu'ils ont appelé
votre banque ? Ah bah parce que la
banque a eu euh l'idée de m'appeler. Ils
m'ont dit tiens, on nous pose des
questions un peu particulières. Il faut
dire que c'était amusant mais la la
personne qui on m'a appelé plusieurs
fois et moi j'habite en province en
province où je suis assez un peu connu,
on va dire. Et donc les gens m'aiment
bien. J'ai un peu de protection locale,
on va dire et donc ils ont eu la
gentillesse de m'appeler pour me dire
tiens, on nous demande des informations
sur vous. Voilà.
Bon mais de toute façon la DG la DGSI
fait son boulot. La DGSI m'arrêterait en
sortant d'ici, j'ai aucun problème.
Ils font leur boulot.
Mais c'est eux des eux ils sont
victimes. C'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre. C'est des gens qui sont
victimes.
On les on leur mque quand on leur parle
pas du financement de Daesh par une
société française qui a joué un rôle
important. On les prend pour des cons
et on leur dit après il faut aller
lutter contre le terrorisme, faites des
heures sup, passer la nuit dans une
voiture, allez risquer votre peau dans
une mosquée.
Alors qu'en fait le gros le gros du
tuyau, on pouvait l'arrêter largement.
Ils sont plus politiques ou moins
politiques que la DGSE ?
Je saurais pas le dire. Ça dépend sans
doute des gens qui les quand vous avez
un score signe à la tête, c'est quand
même plus préjudiciable. Euh
c'est
ça dépend de des des gens qui les
dirigent. Mais le
rêve absolu ce serait de les voir
indépendants
du système politique ou d'avoir un
contrepouvoir parlementaire.
Je vous donne un exemple.
La députée Frédéric Duma a posé
plusieurs questions écrites suite à des
informations que j'avais donné et
cetera. Bon, elle pose quatre questions
écrites. Quand vous posez une question
écrite à un ministre, il est censé
répondre.
Il a 2 mois pour répondre. En gros,
c'est l'usage. Bon, le problème, c'est
qu'à la Chambre des députés, vous avez
577 députés.
Et donc chaque année, il pose en gros
20000 questions écrites. Et donc
maintenant les ministres se mettent
derrière ce paravant en disant "Mais
regardez, oh on nous pose trop de
questions écrites donc on va pas
répondre.
Ça sert à rien. Pourquoi respecter le
parlement ? Ça sert à rien.
De mémoire alors ce qui est sûr aux
États-Unis vous avez 100 sénateurs.
En France, on peut le vérifier
rapidement 345.
Aux États-Unis, vous avez à peu près 300
et quelques représentants, vous avez 577
députés en France. Donc en gros, c'est
un volume de 40 %. Donc ouais, on mange,
on donne à manger à tout le monde.
Voilà, tout le monde veut manger. Et
donc le député, bah il y en a qui font
des efforts mais euh il est pas plus
considéré que celui qui fait rien.
Et moi, je trouve ça dommage. Prenez le
cas d'un J'ai pas de peu importe
l'étiquette qui soit même du Front
National ou du Rassemblement national ou
de quoi que ce soit, c'est pas un
problème. Prenez le cas de de Hugo
Bernal ici qui est lui, je crois à
France insoumise.
Il est surtout président d'une
commission qui permettrait à la enfin
qui travaille sur la justice
indépendante. Comment rendre la justice
plus indépendante en France ? C'est une
question majeure.
Tous les députés devraient soutenir. Peu
importe le parti, ça c'est transpartisan
comme question d'avoir une justice
indépendante,
mais il est tout seul et donc son
travail bien que très méritoire, il fait
tout ce qu'il peut, il met vraiment
vraiment tout son cœur, on le sent bien
mais ça ne servira à rien.
C'est dommage.
Question internet. La double bague façon
Macron, ça représente quoi ? La double
la double bac façon Macron, ça
représente quoi ?
Alors euh ça, je suis marié simplement
et ça c'est une chevalière que j'ai
depuis euh 16 ans, depuis que j'ai l'âge
de 16 ans. Donc c'est un souvenir
d'enfance, on va dire. Voilà, rien de
plus. Il y a pas de il y a pas de signe
mystique ou quoi que ce soit. C'est
voilà.
Alors, question internet. Les temps
difficiles créent des hommes forts. Les
hommes forts créent des périodes de
paix. Les périodes de paix créent des
hommes faibles. Les hommes faibles
créent des temps difficiles.
Est-ce qu'on va être exposé à des temps
difficiles ?
Incontestablement, oui,
incontestablement.
Mais on fait tout pour.
À chaque fois qu'on é qu'on a une
élection, on met en place des gens qui
nous disent "On va faire des réformes et
on met en place des gens qui ne les font
jamais."
Donc au bout d'un moment, c'est ce que
je vous expliquais auparavant, vous avez
un moment le balancier qui commence à
sérieusement cogner. Et voilà, vous avez
un exemple tout bête en matière de
corruption qui est un sujet qui est
préoccupant au niveau de la France, au
niveau de la corruption contenu du
niveau de la corruption en France.
Vous avez deux organismes Cherpa et
anticorps qui ont un agrément pour
porter plainte dans le cadre de la
corruption. Bon,
se porter partie civile euh cet
agrément, il n'est valable que 3 ans.
Donc tous les 3 ans, il faut demander au
ministère de la justice si le monsieur
le ministre veut bien renouveler
l'agrément.
Évidemment, les affaires de corruption
c'est jamais 3 ans. Kashi ça a duré 25
ans. Toutes les affaires, Uramine, j'en
parle même pas, c'est 10 ans aussi mais
bon toutes les affaires sont longues.
Donc quand vous bloquez les gens en leur
disant bah on vous donne l'agrément, pas
de problème. OK, vous avez un agrément.
Donc au niveau international la France a
bien des organismes qui ont un agrément.
Bravo ! Mais l'argent c'est 3 ans. Donc
si jamais ça dérape, si vous êtes
efficace,
adieu l'agrément.
Alors très simple, vous voulez lutter
contre la corruption, bah l'agrément, il
passe de 3 ans à 8 ans ou de 3 ans à 5
ans
avec des contrôles. Ouais, il y a pas de
problème. Mais plus long,
ça demande pas d'argent, ça demande pas
des heures de réflexion.
On a on a un nouveau ministre de la
justice là qui a qui a qui connaît son
boulot du pont Moretti.
P on connait plein de choses sur lui
d'ailleurs.
Et ben et ben il peut décider ça. Non,
il le fera pas.
Voilà, ça se paye.
Ah, il est intègre.
Vous avez la Cour de justice de la
République est intègre
aussi. Candidat Macron à l'élection
présidentielle. Je vais supprimer la
Cour de justice de la République
quand ?
Avant la fin de son mandat.
Donc on ne fait pas les réformes. Alors
oui, qu'on soit fort ou faible, on va
prendre.
Et c'est malheureux. C'est malheureux
pour nos jeunes. Ouais. Qu'est-ce qu'il
faut qu'il fassent les Français ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'il fassent nos
jeunes
pour les plus jeunes ? regarder à
l'étranger.
Non mais non mais
ça c'est clair. Ah ça c'est
non je peux pas vous laisser dire ça.
Pour nos plus jeunes, il faut qu'il se
protège et qu'il regarde à l'étranger.
Ça c'est sûr.
Il faut protéger la patrie jusqu'au bout
et coûte que coûte.
Oui mais à ce moment-là il faut il faut
trouver un moyen de faire ses réformes
de donner du poids au parlement. Ça
c'est sûr. Avoir un parlement beaucoup
plus petit mais efficace.
C'est quoi ce conseil de quitter le
navire là ?
Se protéger. Il y a un moment où on voit
que ça va être on peut on peut pas
réformer. On peut pas réformer. Ça ça va
dans le mur
quoi.
On garde les parents mais les enfants on
les protège. Voilà, c'est ça l'idée. Le
pays et le pays
où ils veulent mais des pays qui si
possible si possible si possible des
pays qui n'ont pas un poids de des
public comme le nôtre. Non
mais la France
oui la France elle en est là mais elle
en est là. Elle en est là. Regardez ce
qui se passe en France. Regardez le
nombre de manifestations. Pourquoi il y
a toutes ces manifestations dans la rue
? Parce que vous n'avez pas d'expression
parlementaire. Vous n'avez pas de
contrepoids
parce que vous avez un Bruno Le maire
qui refuse d'aller au Sénat.
Il considère que c'est de la merde.
Comment vous savez ça ?
Ben parce queil y a eu récemment, il
s'est fait interpeller par le Sénat.
Mais il s'en fout, ça n'a servi à rien.
Il n'ira pas plus se présenter au Sénat.
Il considère que ça n'a pas de sens.
Alors c'est la mer le Parlement n'a pas
de sens,
c'est la merde en France. Donc il faut
il faut se barrer comme les
à un moment ou à un autre ça ne sert à
rien de réélir quelqu'un qui va faire la
même chose que le précédent.
Vous allez voter quoi ? Vous avez voté
quoi ?
Alors la dernière fois c'était on avait
le choix entre Marine Le Pen et Macron.
J'ai voté Macron.
Et vous allez voter quoi là ? Oh, je
sais pas qui en aura mais je comprends
que quelqu'un comme le général de
Villier soit séducteur
mais je suis pas sûr que ça soit la
réponse.
Mais qu'il soit séducteur auprès d'une
population qui en a marre, ça oui, je
comprends. Qu' puisse faire 20 % je
comprends.
Est-ce que ça sera la bonne réponse ?
C'est une réponse sacrément dangereuse.
Il faut bien la poser la question.
Pourquoi c'est dangereux ? parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui est fonctionnaire de
carrière, qui a qui qui connaît pas le
privé, c'est quelqu'un qui est militaire
de carrière, c'est quelqu'un qui est
prodigieusement marqué euh en tant que
religieusement. Je veux dire, c'est pas
le critère laïque le plus la personne
qui fait le le plus preuve de laïcité.
Euh
c'est quelqu'un qui peut poser des
problèmes. C'est pas c'est pas le
nouveau de Gaulle. On demande pas à la
France d'avoir un nouveau de Gaulle. On
demande à la France d'avoir une nouvelle
constitution pour que le président ait
moins de pouvoir et que le Parlement
soit représenté, que le Parlement vive.
Donc il faut bien choisir son candidat.
Il y en a pas beaucoup qui Est-ce que
Est-ce que Christian Tobira pourrait
rentrer dans ce schéma-là ? Peut-être.
faut qu'elle fasse sa profession de foi.
Euh mais le choix est ouvert. Le fait
est c'est que ça fait des années qu'on
échoue. Des années qu'on échoue parce
que la Constitution qui est celle de la
5e République, elle été faite pour de
Gaulle et De Gaul, on en a plus. Et de
Gaulle, il voulait tout concentrer les
pouvoirs. C'est extrêmement dangereux
aujourd'hui avec la technologie dont on
dispose.
Donc il faut redonner son poids au
Parlement et changer de constitution. Ça
c'est sûr qu'on soit de droite de gauche
d'extrême et il faut redonner son
pouvoir au parlement le réduire
et redonner du pouvoir. Il faut que
devant une commission sénatoriale
quelqu'un qui témoigne a le sentiment de
de témoigner devant une juridiction.
C'est le cas, c'est une commission
sénatoriale, c'est une juridiction qui
puisse pas raconter n'importe quoi comme
lors des des euh des témoignages que le
le le député Bernalici a eu pour sa
commission de en tant que de député où
il a eu tout et n'importe quoi et où les
gens s'en foutaient en se disant on peut
bien mentir sous serment, quelle
importance ? C'est des députés.
Buté.
Ben non.
Euh on arrive bientôt à la fin de notre
interview et euh vous avez des bouquins
conseillés à notre communauté ?
Alors déjà, je vous conseille d'acheter
des livres parce que les éditeurs en ont
besoin et euh
euh en fonction de ce que vous voulez,
si vous voulez, si vous aimez l'histoire
euh et comprendre
euh
un peu l'histoire du Moyen-Orient au
travers d'un prisme qui me paraît assez
neutre, bien que marqué, il y a
"Lève-toi et tu le premier qui est un
bouquin qui fait 1000 pages mais qui
reprend euh
euh sur la 3è étage de votre bureau
que j'ai lu avec attention, ça c'est
clair, euh parce que ça représente un
travail d'aimant euh
pour lequel l'auteur a été menacé par le
Mossade et par des éléments de des
services israéliens qui voulaient pas
que ces informations là soient connues
du public, mais il a il a fait un
travail d'historien extraordinaire
euh et qui et respectueux de
l'adversaire
et qui montre bien la limite des des
opérations que peut monter un service de
renseignement et le constat d'échec qui
est pas toujours, on voit toujours la
l'instanté, voilà. Mais sur le long
terme, est-ce que c'est un un échec ou
une réussite ? La limite de ça ? Donc
ça, ce livre là est remarquable.
Et puis euh
euh
bah après c'est si vous aimez
l'histoire, malheureusement ils sont en
anglais mais voilà, vous retrouverez
vous vous trouverez beaucoup de
d'ouvrages en anglais qui qui
travaillent qui qui parlent de la
période de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
avec le sacrifice des agents lors de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale. Vous avez je
vais choquer peut-être certains euh mais
vous avez les mémoires de Autoscorzeni
qui sont remarquables.
Autoscorzenis était le responsable des
commandau d'Hitler.
Après la guerre, après la guerre, il a
travaillé en Espagne et il a été agent
israélien après la guerre. C'est lui qui
a aidé à neutraliser les Allemands qui
travaillaient avec Nasser. Et donc vous
tapez Auto Scorzini, vous verrez ses
mémoires. Je me souviens plus le titre
exact de ses mémoires, mais cet homme-là
a une vie particulière. il a il a
combattu lui. Son obsession c'était pas
euh euh c'était le communisme et et rien
d'autre. Il a pas du tout participer euh
au génocide euh des juifs. Euh
il a fait quelques faits d'armes et
c'est à cause de ça que il a eu une
certaine liberté après la guerre. Euh et
ses mémoires montrent bien le travail
des agents russes euh d'octobre rouge et
tout ça. C'est remarquable. Euh alors
c'est des livres qui sont parus dans les
années 70, mais
un petit dernier pour la route.
Permettez-moi de de dire que
j'aimerais bien qu'on soutienne mon
éditeur aussi parce que c'est quelqu'un
de courageux. Euh c'est pas facile de
publier les livres
il s'appelle votre bouquin
l'homme qui en savait beaucoup trop aux
éditions masso. Euh ça se fait pas de
faire sa publicité mais j'ai du respect
pour Florent Masso parce que c'est pas
facile de publier ces ces livres là. Il
parle de quoi vos bouquin ?
Il parle de toute la période euh
que j'ai connu à partir de disons de de
un peu de de
mon passage de des salles de marché à la
guerre en Irak en passant par le Kivu,
en passant par un peu le Niger, beaucoup
toutes les fraudes d'Areva. Ça montrera
aux gens à quel point
la France a est corrompue, à quel point
c'est difficile d'avoir de la justice en
France. Euh et le travail qu'il faut
faire derrière pour arriver à quelque
chose. Euh et euh ce livre-là, je l'ai
écrit aussi euh s'il peut aider la
justice à progresser, la police à
progresser dans le bon sens, euh bah ça
sera bien. Euh il faut que la
population, elle ait confiance à nouveau
dans sa police, mais pour ça, il faut
que la police, elle soit formée euh et
qu'elle ait des moyens.
Il faut un monde où il n'y ait pas. À
droite, on veut tout que tout soit
police et que rien ne soit justice parce
qu'ils ont peur de la justice. À gauche,
on veut que tout soit justice et rien ne
soit police. Il faut justement pas ça.
Il faut que tout soit police et que tout
soit justice
et que tout soit police formé, qui soit
efficace
et qu'après on a une justice qui soit
juste,
équitable, que ceux d'en haut et la même
justice que ceux d'en bas. Pourquoi ?
Sans cours de justice, sans cours de
sans immunité, sans rien du tout comme
ça.
Vous avez des pays où vous pouvez
envoyer un premier ministre devant un
juge alors qu'il est en fonction.
Vous avez des pays, les États-Unis où
Trump rendait compte alors qu'il est en
fonction.
En France, immunité,
secret défense, secret de l'instruction,
secret ceci,
ça c'est pas possible.
Il y a deux Frances en fait. Il y a Oui,
il y a celle qui
la France des secrets, il y a la France
de de
qui peut faire ce qu'elle veut et il y a
celle qui souffre et qui peut pas
progresser ou qui progressera que si
elle va vers le crime organisé.
C'est ça aussi quand vous êtes
Allez pas voir le vers le crime
organisé.
Non mais moi j'ai conscience que quand
elle a des g
Non mais quand on parle de terrorisme,
il faut bien se rendre compte que un
gosse qui naît dans une banlieu pourri,
il a déjà il a déjà pas le hasard pour
lui. Le hasard c'est la lumière de
l'homme. C'est ce qu'on va appeler la
chance quand ça tourne bien.
Lui son hasard ça va être de dire voilà
est-ce que je vais vendre de la cam ou
pas ?
Son choix ça va être rentrer dans la
légion ou alors vendre de la cam.
Est-ce qu'on peut pas leur donner un peu
une une autre prérogative ? Les gosses
de banlieu sont des gosses courageux.
Faut pour vivre dans ces merdes là, il
faut être courageux. Il faut leur rendre
ça et donc on peut en faire quelque
chose.
En terme de contre terrorisme
d'ailleurs, ils sont pas du tout
exploités.
Ouais.
un un mot sur Julien Nassange.
Alors moi j'ai trouvé depuis le début,
je trouve très regrettable que avant
même Julia la chance, il y a aussi cette
affaire de Bradley Mannings euh qui
aurait jamais dû être Chelsea Mannings
maintenant qui aurait jamais dû être
condamné. Il aurait dû être jugé mais
pas condamné comme il a été, pas
incarcéré comme il a été. Euh Julien
Assange, il a joué, il a fait beaucoup
pour la démocratie.
Vous n'avez pas idée à quel point les
Wikileaks câbles diplomatiques ont pu
aider à résoudre certaines affaires et
donc ça a été un vrai progrès. C'est
quelqu'un qui mérite d'être accueilli en
France.
Ça nous grandirait
malheureusement. Bah on voit que de même
de même que comment il s'appelle ?
Snowden.
Snowden. Snowden. Il a aidé le monde
entier. Il s'est sacrifié mais il a aidé
le monde entier. Il a ouvert les yeux du
monde entier. La Cour suprême lui a
donné raison aux États-Unis.
Et pourquoi pourquoi ne pas simplement
euh pardonner
et lui donner raison ?
Parce que ça pourrait en inciter à
d'autres à faire la même chose.
Et ben tant mieux.
Ouais. On
n' jamais construit les systèmes
d'information et les agences
d'information pour aller contre le
peuple.
Ça a été on les paye. Vous les payez
avec votre salaire ces gens-là. C'est
pour vous qui sont là, c'est pour vous
qui s'engagent,
c'est pour vous qui vont tomber.
Une question à Odine que je vois sur le
chat. Est-ce que c'est un sabotage de la
République ?
Un sabotage de la République ? Euh, une
trahison.
Forfaiture.
Oui. Quand quand vous voyez
Est-ce que c'est pas une opération
extérieure ? Non non non, il y a pas de
complot. Faut pas voir les complots, les
truc. Il faut voir notre médiocrité là
où elle est. Il faut la regarder dans
les yeux. On est responsable de notre
destin. On vote, on est responsable de
notre destin, on paye nos impôts. On a
des droits parce qu'on paye nos impôts
dans un pays qui s'appelle la France. Il
faut que les fonctionnaires le
comprennent. Il faut que les militaires
le comprennent.
Est-ce que vous comprenez aussi la
lassitude des fonctionnaires ? Oui, bien
sûr
parce que au-dessus il y a grand Tou qui
est encarté qui machin quand on voit
l'ambassade américaine, l'ambassade de
XP qui font de l'écoute en plein milieu
de Paris et que nous on est encore à
pédaler avec une petite trentainette.
Je vais vous raconter
un fait réel.
Il y a il y a 3 4 ans, la société Boloré
a posé des rails de train en plein
milieu de Niamet, de l'aéroport jusqu'à
en plein centre-ville de Niamet.
La société M, c'est quoi ?
Ouais, société Boloré logistique.
Bah, j'y étais donc
au Niger, même vous prenez Google Map,
vous allez sur Niam, vous allez voir des
rails et ces rails ils vont nulle part.
La première fois que la locomotive est
montée sur les elle a déraillé.
de la derrière nous parce que Boloré
c'est la France c'est nous c'est un
représentant de la France il y a des
élément de la DGSE chez Boloré
donc
comment vous savez ça
mais moi j'y étais vous pouvez aller à
Niam moi j'y étais 7 ans au Nigéri
vous savez qu'il y a il y a des éléments
de la DGSE chez Boloré
parce que Michel Roussin est un ancien
de la DGSE et que c'est connu et que et
que Boloré embauche les anciens de la
DGSE c'est connu c'est pas c'est pas un
secret c'est pas interdit non plus hein
vous Vous avez le droit mais c'est
l'image de la France. Ce que je veux
dire par là, c'est que Boloré, c'est
l'image de la France à l'étranger.
L'image de la France à l'étranger, c'est
d'avoir construit des rails qui ne vont
nulle part en plein milieu d'une
capitale africaine.
Est-ce qu'on ferait ça ? Est-ce qu'on on
imagine seulement une fois qu'une
société étrangère
construise des rails en plein milieu de
Paris et disent
"Débrouillez-vous avec, il y a rien, ça
sert à rien."
Euh, je vais vous poser la dernière
question qui n'est pas une question qui
est laissée un conseil pour les les
jeunes générations. Je vous laisse
réfléchir. J'en profite pour dire
abonnez-vous à la chaîne parce qu'on on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
énormément de personnes qui n'étaient
pas abonnées et qui commentaient, qui
venaient nous voir et qui venaient
régulièrement mais ils oublient de
s'abonner. Donc abonnez-vous, appuyez
sur la petite cloche pour avoir les
notifications, soutenez-nous sur Tipi et
maintenant vous pouvez nous donner votre
conseil pour les jeunes génération.
Ne perdez pas espoir
et et soyez déterminés, ça c'est sûr.
Vous ne réussirez que si vous êtes
déterminé, peu importe ce que vous
fassiez
dans le mal comme dans le bien, mais
soyez déterminés.
Marque changé. Merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]